[Music]
so
[Laughter]
hey you guys oh and as soon as i come on
my creepy phone
i swear to god i just turned the volume
down
like
two minutes ago yeah and it's back up
again yeah my [ __ ] phone's haunted
you move the camera just a little bit
and your spock is a little bit
yeah i kind of rearranged in here a
little bit yesterday yeah i got
rearranged the whole studio it's
different now yeah you can't do it
though yeah you can't see so much
because i moved like mostly like over
there where my desk and stuff was and i
moved some of the bookshelves
and uh i got like a little
couch
like
not not really a couch but just like a
kind of a little
loveseat type situation but that hasn't
come yet so it's gonna go over there and
it's got like a little coffee table with
it
yep today is friday it is and uh i got
some new drinks here i don't know what
this is okay danny rowling says audio
sounds fine yeah i was worried about it
earlier because when i was rearranging
yesterday obviously i had to unplug some
stuff because i was moving it and then i
made a video earlier today and when i
listened to it back it sounded really
like not unlistenable but it sounded
weird like it didn't sound as good as
usual
so hopefully but i [ __ ] with the with
the settings so it should be okay now
it's pretty weird
what is sparkling tequila blood orange
sparkling tequila
you
it's kind of like uh
you know those sparkling waters yeah
like that without any sugar yeah that's
what this is with tequila in it
so like lacroix or yeah so i like like
a little bit tequila it's not bad it's
just it's not sweet
would you you got him at sam's yesterday
yeah he did a big sam's run yesterday
yeah
they're
okay they're okay it's only a hundred
calories it's like diet it's like diet
tequila
i wouldn't realize that how much tequila
is in there like what's the percentage i
can't see them
alcohol by volume see i can't see it
probably weak
so hey everybody like everybody's here
five percent alcohol oh well it's you're
gonna have to drink like all [ __ ] 12
of those to even get a buzz on well i'll
just i'll just drink one and i'll go
back making a make
just like a little refreshing thing you
know it's refreshing yeah
uh dj maniac says i'm doing thai food
tonight coconut curry chicken soup and
noodles with peanut sauce holy crap that
sounds delicious that um
is there any way i can turn that light
off what light that one over there that
one's oh the lamp get me right in the
eye yeah it's got a little um
thingy on the thingy
you know okay i don't i can't remember
words
what's going to turn my fan on i always
got to turn the fan on that's right
all right
yeah that thai food actually really does
sound good we just had
i had totally forgotten that you made
that chicken curry that you made you
said you made it how long ago was that
like a month ago it was frozen though i
thought that there wasn't any left over
but he's like oh i found some and we you
know he went to sam's yesterday so he's
like well i needed some more room in the
freezer and we forgot this was in here
so we made it for lunch today tasted
just as fresh as it did when you made it
it was that's mayor fryers an air fryer
slash broiler thing on sale that sam's
for 99 bucks i bought it
either i could have bought another ice
machine but i said now i have a good for
ice machines right now yeah we don't
need another ice machine air fryer i've
actually kind of been wanted to get one
trying to figure out how to how to work
it yeah if any of you all have an air
fryer and you have any good like ideas
about it we
you made uh french fries in it yes yeah
it turned out okay yeah that was pretty
good they just take a lot longer to cook
than i thought they they would yeah so
we had to eat the burgers first and then
yeah and it came with that
it came with a little cookbook and it
said to pre to boil those french fries
first for
five minutes and then
cover them with the man that [ __ ] didn't
work they fell apart had to turn those
[ __ ] potatoes into mashed potatoes
so uh no just [ __ ] cover them with
oil and [ __ ] salt them and put them
in there
for to go about it took a while i had to
mix them around it was probably close to
60 minutes so it wasn't
wasn't time efficient
well
it's less messy and less fattening i
guess than like doing you know doing
them deep fry that's probably the only
thing tila says air fryer chicken wings
is awesome
um i got
i bought four whole chickens
i haven't uh actually have frozen i
froze two of them
uh so i got two of them that are thawed
i might try to cook a whole chicken in
there and see what that's like
that'd be pretty good yeah i imagine
that'd be pretty good we'll see what
it's like
hooray yeah taylor says uh sparkling
tequila what flavor did you answer that
it's blood orange right blood orange
that's blood orange it came in a 12 pack
each one of them i think there's two of
the same kind
so six different flavors
i thought they were all blood orange
they all the all of them looked the same
no they're different they're all the
same color but they all have a
different uh flavor written on them
no that's not gonna do the trick
[Laughter]
too weak
well yeah like i said you should have
looked at this
like i said that might be kind of like
um look not lacroix but like uh
what's that other thing white claw that
everybody was drinking yeah it's like
only try
no i don't like tequila
uh cheryl says i have two chickens in my
freezer can't wait for barbecue weather
yeah i mean to be honest it's already
barbecue weather here uh it was 80
degrees today
fahrenheit so
a little warm i just wanted to
experiment with a thing it wasn't that
expensive so
just gonna try it i want to get one of
those damn quick pots isn't it they call
it quick pop what instant pot insta pot
it's like a pressure cooker and a slow
cooker at the same time i want to get
one of those too honestly pretty much
everybody because remember i've said the
last couple times that i'm obsessed with
those uh budget grocery challenges that
like all these people do
you know it's like i ate for a week on
ten dollars from dollar tree or whatever
and pretty much all of them have instant
pots well because they're really good
for making beans yeah uh you know making
rice because you could just kind of set
it and forget it yeah and it's like you
know well because it's like a pressure
cooker but not
yeah it's i guess it's like a lot this
indian woman that's a friend of the
family name's amy she married a doctor
over there in sanford
he's well he's he's from india too
she told me to get one of those things
she's got a bunch of indian recipes she
sent me the youtube channel that she
cooks off of
and she said indian food's [ __ ] best
out of those quick pots
yeah i can see that i mean anything
that's just kind of like a one pot yeah
meal that doesn't have to be constantly
monitored curries and lentils and there
you go and all that stuff that's another
thing that a lot of people make
because like i said those a lot of those
videos that i watch it's like tons of
different people that do them like the
budget challenges pretty much all of
them have an instant pot and like i said
if you're doing budget challenges they
almost always have beans and rice or
lentils yeah um and they'll make like
the whole pot
and then use it in like four or five
different things
like over the course of the week but
yeah it seems really have you guys seen
i don't know like i don't know if it's
as cool as it looks
but i saw an ad for it a while back it's
kind of expensive i will say but it's a
thing it's called a suvi and it's a
kitchen robot
and it's about the size of like well
it's narrower than a microwave but it's
a little bit taller than microwave so
it's small there's like two zones
and you can basically make almost
anything in that [ __ ] it even
refrigerates the food until your time
until it's time to cook it like you set
a timer on it and it'll do two different
zones so you can cook like vegetables on
one part of like meat on that it'll cook
it at different times
um and you just you can either it comes
with um like all of these recipe cards
and you just uh scan the
qr code and it automatically like sets
it up for you and you can like set the
timer or whatever so i think it's like
400
but it does like like i said pretty much
everything and then it has a thing that
like a starch cooker that cooks like
pasta and rice and if you get those two
i don't know how much that is but if you
get those two things together
it seems like you don't even really need
an oven or a microwave or anything
because it does
everything yeah which i was like
that's kind of cool as you know i don't
know if it's as cool as it looks on the
commercial but this one comes with like
a little cast iron
square pan
that can go in there and it's not
totally cast iron it's if it's cat it's
not cast iron it's trying to be cast
iron it's kind of like a thick metal
yeah
and i was looking at that and i was
going like that probably work for the
pizza crust if i put dough in there yeah
i could probably make a pizza in that i
just would i don't know if it
could my stone works so well you know
but i was just kind of curious
what that would be like to cook a little
pizza on that thing
but it's just an experiment you know it
didn't cost that much if that thing
ain't worth the [ __ ] we will move it up
here and put it in a break area or
something
yeah no way you can just cook it
like a toaster oven yeah get out of it
well i was thinking about getting a
toaster oven for up here anyway and like
a little microwave eventually i don't
know i might not do it right now but
because i mean i already we already have
a coffee pot yes i sound lazy as [ __ ]
like not being able to go downstairs
again
but it is kind of when you have time
when you have an office up here i
understand what she's doing
sometimes going downstairs to do things
like get ice cubes it's a pain in there
up and down the downstairs it's like
look i just want a glass of water
i don't want to have to go all the way
downstairs at all we got so much we got
so much room up here we can just set up
a [ __ ] like a break room that's what
i'm saying i want to put a bar up there
in that living room this house has five
[ __ ] bedrooms and it has a little
living room downstairs and a big huge
living
room bedrooms it's more like three
well because the other rooms are very
[ __ ] small like you know one of them
is small is it it's my gym
yeah it's just guys you had to live in
that room that'd be like something for a
kid
well yeah that's well that's why they
make some of the rooms are smaller right
but i mean our bedroom is pretty big
pretty big yeah i mean your bedroom is
pretty big this room i didn't even
realize that's why i started like
rearranging like i said i don't think
you can tell too much because i didn't
move too much of the artwork in the back
but um i did move like some of the
bookshelves and things and i made like
kind of a cubicle because i was thinking
to myself this room
is massive
really um
and so i was like well [ __ ] i'm gonna
make like a big cubicle here with my
office because i used like the two big
bookshelves over there to like block it
off a little bit and make like a little
path into the room and i said [ __ ] i
could put like a little sitting area
over there like a little couch and a
little table it's like i could sit over
there and read now that i bought this
thing i might change [ __ ] up because
some of this [ __ ] does not make sense
that little room right there
has a big [ __ ] closet and then my man
cave which is kind of like my room is
bigger than that but it has a little
closet it doesn't make any sense really
ought to knock a hole in this wall and
put a room put a put a door right there
to make that room part of this room
there really shouldn't be a separate
room there
yeah i mean we don't need it don't need
well it's it just should be a door right
there yeah you know uh the layout's kind
of weird which is one of the reasons why
this house didn't sell instantly
you know
i'm just happy to have gotten it because
this place is gonna [ __ ] blow up it's
the whole [ __ ] state is blowing up
you're lucky you're lucky to be able to
buy a house like this here in florida
right now
and
if this house for 475 000 had a [ __ ]
badass layout it was sold a couple years
ago
the reason why it didn't sell is because
it had people in it at the time renters
in it
and the reason why we had renters in it
because it wasn't snapped up early
because the layout is kind of [ __ ]
crazy
i mean it's it is but it's not that
crazy i mean like i said i've lived in
tiny ass studio apartments and stuff
most of my life so
so i'm just kind of like fine with
whatever because this is like easily the
downstairs this is easily the biggest
house i've ever lived in by quite a
large margin the downstairs living room
is [ __ ] crazy as [ __ ] it looks like a
[ __ ] tuscan [ __ ]
outside [ __ ] bar it's got [ __ ]
well the columns coming that's what we
should turn it into yeah that's what it
should be it looks like it looks like it
should be a cafe down there not a living
room it's just [ __ ] crazy well like
it's going to be a little living room a
little diamond room sit side by side and
then there's a big ass dead
and then there's a
another
bedroom downstairs is supposed to be the
master bedroom but it's not big
but it has a big bathroom and a big
closet it doesn't make sense the
proportions are all off
now and
there were other houses like this in
this neighborhood just like it that have
a whole nother wing added onto it and it
probably made sense in other versions of
this house these things were put
together out of a damn catalog
well yeah i mean any any neighborhood
like this is there's you know x amount
of floor plans right and because we've
if you walk around this neighborhood
there's other houses that look almost
exactly like this one
yeah and i imagine the interior layout
is very similar yeah but i'd be
interested i'm not i mean i'm not
bothered the yeah the the downstairs is
a little weird but i get what they were
doing they're doing like a little bit in
the front
it's like a
that's like your little bitty like
formal living room that nobody sits in
and then there's like a formal dining
room area that's like you know tile
floor and then when you go through to
where the kitchen is there's a little
breakfast nook type thing
and then there's like a small living
room that's like your casual living room
where the kids sit with on the couch and
watch tv
and then there's a master bedroom down
there if you want the master bedroom on
the first floor which some people do um
but then the room that we honestly in
this house this room i kind of feel like
was meant to be the upstairs master
because the bathroom
is attached and there's a dressing room
in between there but this this but when
we first looked at the house because i
told him i'm like well what bedroom do
you want to use for the master because
this one yeah is the master because the
the bathroom is attached and it has like
a big walk-in closet yeah it's crazy in
the dressing room and he's like well i
don't really want to use this one for
the master because he liked the other
bedroom on the other side because it had
like a higher ceiling yeah and this one
just yeah kind of like this low ceiling
the other one has a vaulted ceiling but
it doesn't have a ceiling fan no i
haven't seen the jab but it's bigger the
room's bigger
and i don't know it might be the same
size no it's bigger it's because this
room's pretty big it's bigger i measured
it the other day when i was rearranging
all this furniture to make sure [ __ ] was
gonna fit the way i thought it was going
to
this room
is
15 feet
long yeah
and
12 or 13 feet wide and that's not
including the dressing room and the
bathroom this made more sense as an
office
that's true it just does because you
have a
you have like a little little sink there
a dressing room a walk-in dressing room
and then a bathroom that you can that
can be
accessed on either side
and it's like that's almost like a break
room right there this just makes more
sense as an office than it does a
bedroom yeah
i mean i would have i'm happy with
either like i said i'm not super picky
um you know i'm sure people are bored
with us talking about this house now let
me go
i gotta make a real drink this [ __ ] here
would tasted good this week did you
finish it already oh yeah
oracle says which room is pookie's
favorite for scampering in uh she likes
scampering everywhere uh she likes to
normally if i'm in here because i'm
usually in here pretty much every day
working she just likes to come in here
during the day and she'll curl up in one
of the chairs and just sleep or jump on
my keyboard while i'm trying to work she
does that a lot too and she'll like
sneak up on me here's what she does i'll
be sitting not at this computer but at
my other big computer over there and
i'll be sitting here dude to do like
working all of a sudden i'll hear bro
and then like she'll jump up on this arm
and then jump on the keyboard and i'm
just kind of like okay i just lost
whatever work i was doing so thanks a
lot she like scares the crap on me
pretty much every day because she's very
very sneaky but um she actually likes so
she sleeps in here most of the day in
the big
living room like down the hall which we
haven't really done much of anything
with that's just kind of
where we're just leaving there's a
couple chairs in there and [ __ ] like
that and her big cat tree is in there
and she'll sleep in the cat tree
but she likes to
run up and down that room
and
for a little nine or ten pound cat
she makes an unbelievable amount of
noise running around so it'll be like
four o'clock in the morning
and that's her like galloping
up and down the hall
chasing her little she has like a little
chicken thing that she like she'll pick
it up in one paw and throw it and then
like run after it
because no one's awake to throw it for
her because she's the middle of the
night so she's like well i'll just play
by myself
and she doesn't she doesn't give a
single [ __ ] how much uh noise she's
making she's very very noisy
uh but you can't be mad because it's too
[ __ ] cute cheryl says i love
rearranging my house i do too you know
what
when i was this is going back a long way
even back to when i was a teenager
and i was still like just living in my
parents house
every couple of months i'd be like man
i'm gonna rearrange so i'd rearrange all
my furniture i'd rearrange all my
posters on the walls [ __ ] like that i
just really got into it for whatever
reason
um you know when we first moved into
this house i set up my office
you know it was the first thing that i
set up i said i'm gonna bring all my
[ __ ] over here and i'm gonna like paint
it and do everything because you know we
have to keep the show going so this is
going to be the first place we're going
to furnish and i'm going to fix it up
and so when i did that
and so i was kind of trying to hurry and
i think i did like an okay job but
then a couple days ago i was saying to
myself you know there's a lot of room in
there and i could probably like move
some stuff around
in a way that would look kind of cooler
and
i was like i think i'm gonna do that and
then so
like i said i ordered like some i
actually went to dollar general what are
you doing okay spooky acting crazy i
went to dollar general and like got like
a couple little tables and like some
little shelving units and stuff
and uh so i could move some stuff around
and then i ordered like a little
couch futon situation and like a little
it's like a little coffee table kind of
it's also like an ottoman but it like
lifts up and you can store [ __ ] in it so
i got one of those too but that's not
coming for another couple days
but oh and i also ordered some
cabinet paint so i can paint those
bathroom cabinets because they're
[ __ ] brown and i hate [ __ ] brown
anything
i don't know why they have to make brown
i would prefer you know what i don't i
don't like white either but i would
prefer them to be white than brown i
just don't like brown
you know
um cheryl says my cats are loud as [ __ ]
too always a party at 3am well they
sleep all day so
i don't know i can't be mad and honestly
she wakes up at like 5 a.m and like
jumps on my chest cheryl says she's
saving up for her ice maker that's the
one you get i got the silver one that's
the frigidaire
look how pretty that is 89 i should have
got that red one i'm gonna go back and
get a red one eventually
all right it's about the size of a
[ __ ] popcorn
machine like i said anytime you get an
appliance if they got a red one get the
red one yeah
i love red appliances about that tall
and about that wide and about that deep
and you just put water in it make sure
you filter your water first
i keep i keep a pitcher filtered water
right in that little refrigerator
and just pour it in the top
damn i look weird in there with the way
this lights chicken coming up oh it's
because it's because you put that up to
the camera and it's readjusting yeah
because a lot of times if you do it
again it might go back to normal like a
ghost
and then um because if you put okay let
me yeah yeah there it goes it went back
did it yeah it kind of
so um
just pour you can pour water right
through the ice
it's got all kind of indicators tells
you when it's getting low on water you
just pour it right through the ice it'll
go right through the ice back and go
into the reservoir ice bucket and go to
the reservoir
and it'll steady make ice if you don't
take the ice it doesn't matter it's the
ice is just melting and going back into
the tray and it'll refreeze it again
when the trace if the ice starts to melt
and get low it'll just drop fresh ice on
top of it it's all the same water
yeah every time you go in there and get
some ice out like a minute later you'll
hear a quick queen
like it start like it goes some more
like it's making yeah so it always like
sustains a level until it's out of water
right so i usually turn it on first
thing in the morning so i kind of like
some ice water and [ __ ] when the basket
gets filled it just stays like that
stops making it
if you take some it'll drop some more on
top of it a few minutes later
if you don't ever take it it starts to
melt from the bottom
and the leve level goes down it sees
that the ice is disappearing and it
starts dropping nice new ice on top of
the old ice
but
i've shut it off at night woke up in the
morning and there'd still be ice in
there even though it was turned off
because it's pretty insulated in there
it'll it'll it it doesn't melt quickly
because it's not sometimes like i'll go
in in the morning and sometimes there'll
be a little bit of ice in the bottom
although usually
because i get up really early like
between seven and eight
or sometimes earlier but
uh and i'll just go and that's the first
thing is i'll go there and turn it on so
i can have some ice water so like iced
coffee in the morning if you take so
much ice out of it that that the water's
gone
it'll uh stop making ice and it'll start
flashing a red light it'll just say add
water
just pour it through there
yeah it's super easy to use yeah and
like i said very very handy and it's
pretty quick too yeah you can order uh
89 at sam's
tammy says she has one that's it but she
has the copper one yeah
you got cohen's pretty too yeah copper
black silver and red
i got the silver one should have got
that damn red one god damn it i know
well like i said even the when i was
looking at microwaves and uh toaster
ovens i was looking at the red ones
they're like so pretty yeah tila says
feeling a tad bit guilty right now
visiting my folks and we had to board
the boys at the cat-sitting place oh we
check on them and they are pissed i bet
i can't imagine like what pookie would
feel like if we like left her someplace
okay so it's friday it's open lines
tonight if you guys want to talk about
anything you want to talk about any
other cases that we mentioned before on
the show if you want to ask any
questions about paranormal stuff or just
anything science then you just drop a
comment in the comment section and we'll
get to it but in the meantime we're
going to talk about [ __ ] like food or
movie movies or music or whatever with
the con
the subjects can go anywhere because why
because we're drinking
[Laughter]
uh
yeah i don't well pookie got me today i
didn't show you look look right there on
my leg but you stand on your shoulders
well she okay well she jumped up on my
desk and she scared the crap out of me
because like i didn't see her and she
just like jumped up on there and then
jumped up on there and like scared the
[ __ ] out of me and then she was trying
to jump back down
and my legs were because i have this
long skirt on and i think she thought
that that was my leg yeah so she jumped
into like the skirt so there was like
nothing there for her to hang onto and
she was like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and
like she just like grabbed my thigh and
i was like
it was yeah she didn't mean it cheryl
says that's the one she's getting
yeah it's pretty snazzy i mean i'm into
it
yeah so far i've been happy with it
yeah i mean us too like i said it's just
the house is kind of fancy i'm having
more landscaping done to it that'll make
the the value of it go up because the
landscaping was [ __ ] up real basic
um
having
the entryway [ __ ] the concrete busted
out and have a new one built in there
just using all local talent you know i'm
out in the country so we these guys are
everywhere you can get them to come work
little by little they're jumping from
one place to the next they got the
skills you know you can just get
a little contractor he goes yeah i can
do that just give me a couple days i'll
get all the [ __ ] together you know might
take him a week or so but he'll come
back with everything he needs and does
it
and the prices are good you know so
eventually and i'm this is kind of down
the road because i know it's going to be
expensive eventually i would like the
driveway done in pavers yeah because the
driveway is the driveway is really long
yeah and it's really like it has a lot
of cracks in it and a bunch of oil
stains and a bunch of oil stains because
the renters that were here before there
was like a bunch of them living here and
you know this is like a kind of a big
house and so they every one of them had
a car so there were like five or six
cars and there's a two-car garage but
um you know it looked like they weren't
using that i don't know no i don't think
they were using it they were probably
storing stuff in it yeah i imagine and
uh whatever the cars were they were
jalopies because they were just chopping
[ __ ]
oil and brake fluid everywhere you just
see spots going all down it's just got
to be
and
it's just slabs of concrete so it
cracked
it needs to be the cracks need to be
filled or
maybe even busted that out [ __ ]
replace it with tarmac but there's
standards you know the hoa there's only
certain things that they'll take you can
have pavers
i don't know if you can paint it though
you might be able to cover it with
tarmac
i honestly most of the driveways when we
walked around were just like regular but
there were a cup there was one house i
can't remember where it was but we
passed it and they had really really
nice flavors
and i was kind of like ew i wouldn't
mind having that done but i'm sure that
was like
that's gonna be really expensive though
because that was like really really nice
looking though
um yeah cheryl said i'm always covered
in bruises get a puppy they said it'll
be fun they said
pookie's not much of a scratcher to be
honest oh thank you ian england
thank you thank you very much
that's very nice 20 super chat early on
and we haven't even done anything yet
we're not even drunk we're not even
being funny
murder hornet asks tom how much test is
too much in a week
uh well it depends on how much you weigh
and what your goals are
and um
if you're just running a testosterone
base
you're gonna run a testosterone
basically you can do something like lay
in anabolics an anabolic stack
on top of that
the weight that you're gaining is not
coming from that test it's coming from
the anabolic so you can run something
light you can be depending on what it is
some of you could probably drop that
down to 100 milligrams a test a week
if you're doing something like the
anabol
because the anabol is a lot like test
but basically about 200 would be
a decent base
if you wanted to bump up on top of that
most i've ever heard of would be about
700 a week some guys have done that if
you can handle it
now the dudes that were doing that
were 200 something pounds you know
because they and they're lean
so it's a lot of muscle that they're
trying to supply
400 is easy
i'd say most of most i'd probably be 700
if you can do that much man why aren't
you doing something like
like a real anabolic you know
um
winstrol
cannonball
injectable not pills you know but uh and
then um
you know [ __ ]
deck of durability
dollar for dollar though you know
everybody knows is the one i won't even
[ __ ] with that one which is trend
dollar for dollar trend will [ __ ]
turn you into a beast
but just
test is not something you want to take a
whole lot of you know not unless not
unless you want to lose all your hair
and
[ __ ] grow a bunch of [ __ ] hair on
your back you know
it's very androgenic it's a one-to-one
anabolic and androgenic ratio
so i i don't know if that's answered
your question or not
cheryl says jenny needs a black flower
garden yeah ooh that'd be neat
um
and then john gore says get a moat with
gators
h-w-a won't allow it
we could we could be sneaky yeah
[Laughter]
yeah we'd have to be cranky with that
you see he's got a big almost an acre of
property it's just shy of an acre which
pisses me off
because a little bit more room and i'd
have an acre and i'd be able to shoot
here
if you have a backstop i'd be able to
shoot here well somebody's shooting
around because i hear people shooting
all the time yeah
i mean it's pretty rural like i said if
you don't go if you go just a little way
out i think it's 0.8 acres
or 0.9 acres
so there's a huge back out there i'm
gonna [ __ ] make a big old garden out
of there
and put some fruit trees i'm gonna have
a dab of fruit trees and avocado trees
and uh
uh gonna make this [ __ ] planter
[ __ ] do potatoes in there
and uh broccoli stuff like that
you're growing in tomatoes yeah i've
grown some tomatoes and tomatoes grow
some tomatoes that's easy easy to grow
yeah
i'll do them in a planter
planters
but then like the trees i'm gonna have
them in there so it kind of looks
decorative you know
but you'd have to look real hard to see
that it's gonna look gonna look like a
park
that's i'm gonna have it
and then you look and you go wait a
minute
that park [ __ ] yields food see
because i could be straight up [ __ ]
mississippi like my grandparents would
put rows of corn out there and [ __ ]
[ __ ] a whole [ __ ] [ __ ] row of
[ __ ] cotton you know what i mean but
they'd [ __ ] hoa would kick my ass
like what the [ __ ] you doing out here
nothing yeah but there's a couple other
people i've noticed around i go hey man
there's orange trees like oh yeah i see
what you're doing so that's pumpkins
you know so some people are eating off
of there i mean you could do it within
reason as long as it wasn't like an
eyesore no i'm gonna make it [ __ ]
pretty with rocks around it and little
islands and like a little walk path
through see how they i'm gonna have it
once i get it all lit
it's a big sprinkler system see
all right the whole thing's already
systemed out so you might as well put
food out there yeah i mean
why not
you can get an avocado three for the
tree for 30 bucks
yeah
and i love it
[Laughter]
you have all kind of fun [ __ ] out there
like if we we need to grow some pumpkins
too i feel like i'm gonna put pumpkins
out there
i grew some pumpkins in my grandma's
backyard a long time ago like when i was
in my teens
so they're fairly easy to grow yeah i
think you can grow watermelons too yeah
pumpkins watermelons i'll probably put
them up in a pile and put put rocks
around it so it's like an island and you
know what i mean so there's some pretty
plants maybe a bush there
kind of
concealing the fact that that little
island out there [ __ ] makes food
it's a food just go down there and get
some pumpkins because jenny's seen how
much damage i can do on pumpkins what i
can make with pumpkins
two pumpkins i'll have i'll yield
[ __ ] 10 gallons of [ __ ] pumpkin
slurry
it'll be making down pumpkin curry and
pumpkin bread and
pumpkin muffins and pumpkin cookies
you'll get [ __ ] sick of that [ __ ] i
gotta get a lot me i won't i'm gonna get
a couple of them later on lay down
freezers
try to get them for about a hundred
something bucks each
and put them in their garage
to have more freezer space
if i buy one of them cows over there
or you know if we need to hide a body or
something you never know
use that [ __ ] for compost
[Laughter]
you never
you never know what might happen i'm
just saying just jenny's jenny and her
or her horror [ __ ] well that's how
but that's i'm sorry that's how my brain
works
immediately it's either horror or true
crime my brain just turns to that people
i'm sorry give him super chat says tina
gave a super chat thank you sheila
gee grantham's hammer says my annual
physical blood work came back this week
244 uh ngdl is that low oh my who is
this grab theirs
how much was it 244
what about it for nanograms per
deciliter yeah pretty low
pretty low
let me give you an idea
if i come off of everything
if i come off of hrt
and i'm just maybe like on a little bit
of hcg trying to make sure that my
normal system is running i do about 950
nanograms per deciliter that's what my
blood is
when i'm on some good [ __ ] when i'm on
200 milligrams a week
test
i'm not talking about anything else just
test
more like
1300 nanograms per deciliter
i'm boosted i'm very much boosted then
if [ __ ] other things are involved
like winstral or [ __ ] anavar it's
gonna be higher
maybe 2000 1600 probably but
i'm not doing a whole lot
it's kind of low lower doses just real
even just kind of fold one thing in and
run that for a little while and then get
that out of the system and then maybe
put something else in there
the idea is not i'm not an ifbb pro
bodybuilder i'm not
trying to [ __ ] win the olympia i'm
far too old for that i showed you what
what my goals are my goals are to look
like that chinese dude at 73.
[ __ ] 73 years old
he looks better than me
that dude will probably live into his
hundreds
if he doesn't get cancer
cancer eventually can get you
i mean
if something else doesn't get you first
cancer will get you it will eventually
get you yeah if other things but he that
oh that that dude is going to die strong
and he's gonna die handsome
he's a handsome chinese guy
[ __ ] with a fantastic physique he
doesn't have any plastic surgery on his
face and he looks about almost like my
age
and he's 73.
and it's because he kana
it was just about maintenance
and replenishing and restoring
the body's
hormones which are naturally lost
because your production goes away as you
age you've got to replace those hormones
your teeth fall out you replace your
teeth with false teeth your hormones
fall out you replace your hormones with
synthetic alternatives
and the technology and the knowledge is
there put in some tests
maybe put in some other stuff
that'll help you if you're in training
and it's not to get [ __ ] huge it's
just to enhance
to enhance and to keep your body strong
to help you fight off the effects of
[ __ ] aging and
to get away from depletion
you've got to start it early around 50
maximum
if knowing what i know now i would go i
would have went on at 40.
i would have looked a lot better right
now had i gone over 40. if you sit
around and wait till you're [ __ ] 70
and you think oh i'm gonna go on hrt i'm
gonna no the damage is done
damage is done you got to get on it
before the damage happens
murder hornet asks jenny or tom what's
the benefits of being a member of
american homeowners of america or
whatever it's called yeah hoa just means
home owners association and honestly
yeah they're i mean depending not every
neighborhood has one but a lot of these
kind of like plant communities but the
thing about it though is that they're
wildly divergent um in one how much you
pay like some neighborhoods the hoa is
very high some of them are very low and
some of them have different rules and
some of them have different benefits
yeah i feel like uh the one we have here
is
less restrictive in a lot of ways than
the one that was at our old neighborhood
and it's a little bit less i think
you're not going to answer um tila's
question well i haven't gone down there
yet because i'm trying to
she paid for that question where where
is it i was trying to like do some okay
first question of the evening for all
name your top five
horror movie sequels
i'll start with exorcist three a perfect
movie yeah exodus three was good
yeah cause cheryl was well i was trying
to like i said i was kind of behind
because i was like there was some
questions back there that i was
answering but yeah
it depends like hoa just depends what
neighborhood you're in um like i said
they're not the same across the board
they don't have the same rules they
don't have the same benefits um this one
here we get uh cheaper wi-fi it's not
always the best wi-fi obviously because
sometimes we get kicked off but so you
can get around here but it's the best
you can get around here because it's
very rural yeah so uh we haven't had too
much trouble with it and it's not super
expensive i said honestly the hoa here
is cheaper than our old neighborhood and
they do have rules as to like what color
combos you can paint your house and [ __ ]
like that but
it seems every house is it has to have
as it's built on a color scheme it's
less restrictive than our old
neighborhood though it is less
restrictive right so they show you the
color schemes that you can have they
give you the numbers of the [ __ ]
paints and everything what the
hell what the what
what color the house has to be what the
trim has to be what color the door has
to be
and you can't deviate
well you'll have about eight or nine
different choices there's choices like
of yeah these colors go together that
color goes together see all the houses
match the only rule they have is like
you can't paint your house the same
colors as the one across the street from
you or the one on either side of it has
to be because they want a diversity yeah
they have to break out of colors they
don't want a bunch of the same color
houses next to each other and the reason
why they do that is because you got
people that move in here from other
countries
that have [ __ ] up ideas about what
looks good
um damn foreigners yeah yeah
you have people that move in here from
other countries that think that pink is
the color that has to be that the house
should be pink
well some parts of the world they like
pink houses i'm not going to complain
i don't like that but you know there are
some places in the world it's a cultural
thing a pink house means that it's rich
because all the government houses are
the government buildings are painted
pink
so therefore if you're [ __ ] powerful
and rich your house is paid to pink
that [ __ ] doesn't fly in florida they
don't [ __ ] pink houses you know it's
just not gonna happen and you're
depreciating everybody the value of
everybody else's house with that you
also you're gonna have people that find
their way and you know i'm not [ __ ]
being racist against rednecks
because we're rednecks and you know we
have rednecks in the family and [ __ ]
this isn't the kind of neighborhood
where you can hang a [ __ ] used tire
from a tree
or be able to have a [ __ ] uh a
station for pulling motors out of your
[ __ ] truck in the front yard and like
old fridges and all the refrigerators
you know that redneck staple right you
can have to [ __ ] leave the
neighborhood
uh also another thing is is that uh they
go through a criminal background you
cannot you can't be a sex offender and
live here
yeah some uh
some neighborhoods do have that where
they have a rule where if you if you uh
are a sex offender registered sex
offender yeah they won't let you move
so
does this one have that yeah
okay yep
i knew some of them did but i wasn't
sure about that because like i said
there's no there's no um
it's basically up to
the neighborhood like whoever built the
[ __ ] they have everybody has their own
role too he asked that question and we
never answered it well we're getting to
it i was just okay i was finishing up
the deal the best hollywood sequels all
right x is just three i'll put that up
there she said yeah that's really fun
top five horror movie sequels all right
um phantasm too fantastic all the
phantasm sequels yeah all the [ __ ] um
um reanimator sequels
real good bride of reanimator good um
honestly yeah all of them i i liked
actually all of them um about
horror sequels that can that can stand
on their own they're great
and phantasm the whole [ __ ] series
uh every animator the whole series evil
dead too evil dead the whole series
including the television series oh my
god that tv series was so good versus
evil dead if you guys haven't seen it
seriously watch it it's so so good it
was so good
nightmare on elm street three
oh um
all of the omen sequels oh yeah one two
and three they're all good that's it
yeah that's also good they're all good
i'm trying to think of ones that i liked
the sequel better than the original
hmm
i mean obviously the one of the obvious
answers is alien aliens yeah but
i don't know i know that's a sequel but
it's like they're almost kind of they're
both awesome but they're both like
different genres of movies almost
so i don't know so i guess that'd be up
there too
but
i was trying to think if there was any
other good nightmare on elm street
honestly neighbor and elm street 3 is
the best sequel it's not as good as the
original but it's still good although
i've developed a more love for two over
the years
you know the gay one
well you know what i don't know if it's
still on there but if you have shutter
there's actually a documentary and it's
called scream queen
and it's about the guy that was in
nightmare on elm street too
and how his
career was affected by him being in that
movie you know what i mean yeah it's
it's actually really really good it's
really interesting yeah some uh people
have mentioned like cheryl's mentioned
like the dawn of the dead stuff yeah all
of the [ __ ] night of living dead
sequels
yeah all romero's stuff was worth
watching they all ranged from pretty
good to real good yeah yeah
which really i mean with sequels that's
all you can ask for because nobody is
expecting a sequel to be better than the
original i don't think anybody's
expecting that
um but if it's as good
i mean [ __ ] that's that's about all you
can ask for right every now and then
it's better but that's that doesn't
usually happen and we've talked about
why that is before it's just because the
original
you know that's a new property that's a
new thing it's like once you've seen it
now you're saying it again and it's not
going to have the same impact as the
first time so unless they do something
totally different and honestly
making a sequel is like really difficult
to be fair because it's like look do
people want to see more of the same
thing
because if you do too much of that then
people will complain but if then if you
make it too different then people will
complain about that
so in a lot of ways you can't really win
we have talked about road warrior road
warrior wasn't wasn't horror
so it would well that's true but that's
still like a good one right i mean it's
i didn't want to say it's horror
adjacent because it's not but it's still
it's still like a movie that a lot of
people that like horror movies like
apocalyptic action so you know and there
are and there is post-apocalyptic horror
as well so you know it's
um and graham's saying well uh he feels
fine [ __ ] uh with with test levels
yeah what happens is test levels over
time they start to diminish they start
to decline
you kind of uh adapt to it
where it feels okay so you don't really
notice any difference
but to go go and [ __ ] inject some
you'll see what i'm talking about after
about three weeks that [ __ ] starts
flooding in i can remember what it was
like
oh you're like oh yeah i remember what
this was like you know if i could start
going back to your teenage years
um
no there's a big difference
and
when you start bumping a certain you
know
900 nanograms a thousand nanograms
per deciliter
test in your system
all of a sudden you know your recovery
rates your rate of [ __ ] healing up
and
you just start to become more
indestructible your
joints and everything just start feeling
a lot better i had a hard time before i
went on hrt i had a hard time getting
down on my knees or sitting cross-legged
or getting back up he'd be like
oh
or like you know getting down in a
push-up position and looking down
underneath the car you know getting back
up like oh man
now i could [ __ ] just like an acrobat
i feel like i did back in the army
as a [ __ ] young paratrooper you know
no
and it's not an illusion it is it's
because everything's healing back up you
talk to the doctor and your doctor's
like yeah your joints and everything all
the little fluid that your that your
endocrine system makes
to make the damn
buffering fluid inside your joints is
it's you know what i mean is it is
working now so you you know
it kind of sidesteps things like you
know joint pain and
arthritis so there isn't any rub and
cartilage builds up again
bone density builds up you're not as uh
frail you know what i mean it's harder
to break a bone but it takes several
years
of being at that level to replenish and
rebuild all that it's not instant
you go back and look at me 10 months ago
i was recorded right here on the show go
back into the into the archive 10 months
ago and look at me i look totally
different
i look totally different it looks
scrawny compared to now
and i didn't feel as good i feel a lot
better now
i will whip your [ __ ] ass down
that back then
through with my hand was that through
the screen oh yeah
now i'll [ __ ] tell your arms are like
[ __ ]
like a damn you feel [ __ ] crazy
like that chimpanzee that tore that
woman's face yeah
yeah yeah we should do a show like a
[ __ ] chewbacca you know what we
should do a show about people that keep
apes
um you know or trained apes because
that's actually something i've read a
lot of books about and it's actually
kind of fascinating um
you know what i mean
there was a there was a famous chimp
called nemchimsky
uh who
he was on like sesame street and [ __ ]
like that back in the 80s or 70s and uh
i read a whole book about his little
life story and everything and that'd be
good to do a show about yeah grampher
says road warrior is better than mad max
agree with you there uh terminator 2
better than terminator no no no no wrong
not true um
empire strikes back better than star
wars yeah okay i'll agree with that yeah
uh lee warner says oh i've been curious
about this watch the new texas chainsaw
massacre sequel on netflix today
predictable lazy boring [ __ ] i kind of
feel like i'm here in mixed reviews of
that
um
i don't know did that really need to be
made honestly and i'm going to say
obviously the original texas chainsaw
massacre that's the og and
that just can't be replicated i will say
though that the remake that they did in
2004
not bad
not as good as the original obviously
but i didn't hate it so
there's that i actually did go see it in
the theater and i was like oh that was
much better than i was expecting
so i don't really know if they needed to
do another one but whatever grabs to
tell you about the terminator and
terminator 2 just got to disagree go
back and watch them
uh
decades ago would have said you were
right but go back and watch them now
t2 didn't t2 is a good movie but it is
an action movie
it has a lot of flaws in it
things that didn't age well
uh most of it having to do with the kid
i think maybe if if that wasn't in there
then yeah then yeah i think it would be
better and the fact that that arnold is
not playing a villain
um what made terminator 1 so great
is that it is actually a horror movie
disguised
as a science fiction movie it's not
science fiction it's [ __ ] horror
the terminator is a [ __ ] monster
it's a monster it's like it's like jaws
but it's from the future
and it's a technological monster
and it's just a bleak movie
and it is very [ __ ] basic
uh it doesn't
it doesn't force you to believe any
[ __ ] really it's just like a very
simple concept this thing from the
future has come back to the past to kill
this woman because she's going to give
birth to this kid
that's going to give it trouble
and a dude goes from the future comes
back to try to stop it it's kind of
simple
and that's a perfect [ __ ] movie there
should have been no sequels
the more they told more they built on
that [ __ ] story the more [ __ ] up
that story began became
and then they did the cardinal [ __ ]
sin they showed you skynet they should
have never done that
never given a face to that
thing it's better when that [ __ ] is just
not explained
no details it's a lot more mysterious
i try to erase from from my mind t2 3 4
5 6 all that [ __ ]
i pretend like that's not there
even though
terminator salvation
was kind of a fun movie but i kind of
saw it more of a standalone
it was not like one or two at all the
thing about it is like i kind of wish i
mean
there's an argument to be made that you
could make other movies in that same
universe
but yeah making direct sequels i always
feel like you're kind of shooting
yourself in the dick i know why they do
it because they make money um you know
and they generally do even though it's
diminishing returns they do make money
because people want to see something
that's familiar and so they'll pay to
see it but
like i said and i've brought this up
before i'm a big horror fan and i'm a
big fan of keeping stuff not so
ambiguous that you don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on but
the more you keep [ __ ] unknown or
mysterious and stuff like that the
scarier it is yep the more effective it
is the more you explain it
the more you're [ __ ] it up yeah
you're [ __ ] it up that's kind of the
same and honestly when they do a sequel
you kind of can't help but explain it
more because what else are you going to
do yep i mean you have to like expand
and it's really hard to do that while
still
you know
it's hard to do that without like
demystifying what made the first movie
so good in the first place that's what
happened with the with the alien sequel
the alien franchise and the prometheus
stuff they're explaining too much
oh yeah it really should only be alien
one and two three a little bit maybe
but even that had problems they
shouldn't they should have just left it
right there
now then the alien versus predators i
liked them because they didn't really
give you a whole lot of information and
just showed you some cool [ __ ]
that's all you need yeah i mean honestly
if you're gonna do that just make it
like monster fights don't try to like ex
don't try to expand the lore don't try
to add stupid [ __ ] to it just like have
it be monster fights and gore and
people's heads getting pulled off and
stuff and some people didn't like
requiem i can understand why they didn't
like it because it was too dark it was
too dark there's a certain season like
literally literally you couldn't see
what was going on
i think you could fix it
uh i think but you could probably
digitally fix that just to lighten it up
a little bit
um
but i loved requiem i thought requiem
was good uh it was the [ __ ] game
warden shows up alien outbreak of
[ __ ] predaliens
and it didn't go into a big detailed
description
uh that was the problem with predators
that last predator movie
there are too much [ __ ] explanation
global warming and that's crossbreeding
with humans and no
[ __ ] off [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
no you you really should not talk too
much about your monster
let the monster be let it be a monster
the reason why it's a monster is because
you're curious about it it's an unknown
when you give more information just show
don't tell
it it does something new you didn't you
haven't seen that before
that's all you do that's all it is it's
not rocket science
you don't want to know these things
one of my posters is falling down in the
background yeah okay you don't want to
know what these things names are you
don't want to know what planet they come
from you don't want to know motivate you
don't want to know any of that it will
demystify it
that's all i'm saying
can you guys stick that back up there
because that's going to bother me like
you don't just pull it down
no why don't you stick it back up there
because i can't reach that what do you
think i'm [ __ ] six foot six
there's a chair there's a chair right
there there's a chair cookie's in a
chair oh pooky's in the chair yeah oh
yeah i couldn't see her yeah she's
almost the same she's like what she's
looking up at the corner like yeah
i need some more two-sided tape
okay
i didn't have a frame for it so i was
like well i'll just stick it up on the
wall with two sided tape and it's not
like working out
uh all right so tila thank you again
asked another question best drama
sequels
i'm gonna start with the godfather part
two okay
she's like what the [ __ ] she's like [ __ ]
all this oh you scared her poster dude
[Laughter]
she's like i'm gonna blame muto
yeah i mean honestly
godfather two i can't really think of
another one that was
as good as that one
hmm
i feel like dramas don't get as many
sequels as horror movies or sci-fi as
genre movies do you know
you know what's weird i don't know why i
just thought of this but um i guess
because of a video i was watching he
says actually tom's ego is six foot tall
oh no
no it's way taller
yeah
six foot seven foot eight foot yeah
that's my stick man
i probably missed like so many [ __ ]
oh man i was like i was way behind yeah
so texas chainsaw t says texas chainsaws
getting good reviews t it's good to have
you back on the show cause you asked you
say so much [ __ ] it gives us something
to talk about
zach says what's a remake you prefer to
the original
the blob we just covered that one the
other day
uh i actually think that's way better
than the original honestly
the fly
yeah the thing yeah
um
i mean any one that was just like a like
a really old movie or like a cheesy
50s movie or something like that that
was remade
uh you know with some seriousness
that's generally better yeah t comes
back they're saying cheryl's going
that's right tom just let it be a
monster t says that's right show don't
tell tom's exactly
i mean that's kind of like writing 101
writing 101 and that was the problem
with [ __ ] terminator
and and uh did as it went on terminator
started to do too much talent and none
of them showing
instead of [ __ ] t2 what i would have
done is i'd have gone back to the future
back to the future the next movie should
have been in the future
okay it should have been
um
the dude what was his name connor
yeah should have been conor
in the future
[ __ ] fighting the damn terminators
with a young kyle reese
and then the mission to send kyle back
to the past that's what it should have
been
bc that would have been too expensive
and arnold did not want to be he in his
contract he couldn't be a villain
because he was too good as a villain
arnie was built to be a villain
but i understand why
he didn't want to be a villain in movies
because he'd been typecast and he'd
quickly lost popularity
his
his career would have been rude he'd
have been a character actor you've been
a character and he wanted to be a star
yeah
that's a smart move
but yeah career-wise yeah sure but
artistically arnie is the [ __ ]
perfect villain
yeah yeah and
that's one of the reasons why
a total recall worked so well
because he was both the hero and the
villain in that
you realize that yeah
because
he wasn't what he thought he was he
actually was the [ __ ] evil agent that
erased his own brain to [ __ ] go
through the whole so he became a double
agent
he was going against himself remember in
the recordings
remember he had recordings of himself
saying you are me and i work for the bad
guys remember
but you're not but but you as the
audience member you you know when you're
like like my friend little swell he does
not want to believe
that quaid
was
first of all it was the ego trip he's
back at [ __ ]
he's back at recall he paid
for this ego trip
you know what i mean
it was all a fantasy he paid for
but in his fantasy
he was actually the bad guy who had
turned
and become a good guy
in the fantasy that he bought
he had a very elaborate fantasy it was
an elaborate i mean elaborate fantasy so
in a way quade was the bad guy
ian england says event horizon is my
favorite horror movie that's a good
flick actually we reviewed that a while
back i think it was like last year
sometime i think we reviewed that
and
this uh saw two three four and five were
better than saw one you know what i
don't think i saw the first saw
and i'm pretty sure i saw the second one
and maybe the third one
but i don't remember a great deal about
them
so
it's a good series i just i don't know
it's it's not one of the ones that i
like you know jump to i guess it's a
good idea
somebody's just saw possessor by the by
cronenberg
man that was i really liked that yeah
that was uh which one was that that was
brandon chronobrand yeah the new one
yeah that was he was actually as good as
his dad in some ways
yeah it's like it's the same but
different yeah you know what i mean you
can tell that that's david gronenberg's
kid for sure
but he's kind of got his own thing going
on too i'd like to see more of his [ __ ]
is there [ __ ] we haven't seen from him
um he did a movie called oh [ __ ] was the
one he did before possessor what the
[ __ ] was the name of it i reviewed it
did he do upgrade no no who did upgrade
that was um
[ __ ] now i can't remember that was a
cronenbergish kind of movie a little bit
yeah not exactly the same i mean the
thing about cronenberg whether david or
brandon is that the minute you see a
cronenberg movie like
it's just
i mean he might as well be standing
there in front of the camera that's how
distinctive that dude style is
and i kind of feel like some people are
trying to like replicate it and you
can't quite do it you can't quite do it
there's just something
just immediately like cronenbergian
about that gene pool
what was his god damn it what the [ __ ]
was it i i
reviewed it like a few months ago
the one that the one that brandon
cronenberg did before
possessor
[ __ ] i'll probably remember it like 10
minutes from now it was a good it was
really good i liked possessor a little
bit better but the first one was good
too t and mary are talking about uh
having good taste and liking the
marathon man yeah we did we did a review
of marathon marathon man i don't know if
t was uh has seen it our review of it
but
uh yeah that's i love that movie it's a
good movie that's one that's one of his
best movies that uh
dustin hoffman yeah that's one of his
best movies that one in midnight cowboy
he had a lot of good movies in his
heyday i mean god he's been in so
[ __ ] many
what a career that dude has had yeah
seriously
but like all careers i mean he ended up
doing some [ __ ] what was it what was it
yeah outbreak i didn't really think that
was that good he started
he retired yeah good note he retired
before he started doing ridiculous [ __ ]
it's just uh some some of his stuff
started the times had changed it wasn't
so much him well the thing too is that
sometimes actors actresses whoever once
you get older um you know you still need
work and yeah sometimes you're not
getting the same kind of media ass rules
you used to get sometimes you're gonna
be putting some like lame ass hallmark
christmas movie
you know
and honestly i don't begrudge people
being in that i don't you know it's a
job uh that's what their job is and they
need a paycheck just like everybody else
even though they're rich so i don't you
know i'm not quite as sympathetic but
you know
but if they still need work then
honestly i have more respect for them if
they
you know agree to do for example like a
cheesy ass uh hallmark christmas movie
and they do their [ __ ] best at it
even though the movie's terrible
but they show up and they do the [ __ ]
and they take it seriously then that's
gonna get a lot more respect than
somebody that just like [ __ ] phones
it in or whatever so not like i would
not like i watch those movies so i don't
really know so i don't know if they
phoned it or not it doesn't really
matter but yeah uh
zach says i'm amazed a movie like the
godfather got a sequel knowing what kind
of movies would become popular a decade
later yeah that seems like a really
weird and it's it's kind of telling
isn't it that when tila said thank you
that when tila said like best sequels to
dramas honestly godfather 2 was the only
thing that i could think of yeah that
was it because i kind of feel like
dramas
they don't usually i mean you know
they don't usually get sequels they're
usually pretty self-contained
not always but i kind of feel like
sequels are more kind of like a
that's more a horror sci-fi
you know big tentpole movie type of
thing i kind of feel like that's more
like a genre movie type thing
um let's see
john goris i felt that way about all the
michael meyer sequels too much
information yeah exactly i mean the
first halloween is like the perfect
slasher movie
it's like you know the platonic ideal of
the slasher movie
okay
um
but then yeah they just over explained
it and then they went off on that whole
like supernatural thing which what the
[ __ ] was even that and then rob zombie
comes in and look i love rob zombie's
music some of his movies are okay like
his original ones
uh you know if you're in the mood for
that kind of thing
but you know i liked house of a thousand
corpses i liked all that stuff but when
he did the halloween remake and insisted
on showing michael myers as a kid and he
was like beaten up by a stripper mom or
whatever i was just kind of like
this is not
the whole like the whole scary thing of
halloween to me was that
you were never entirely clear whether
michael myers was like a person or
whether he was just like the embodiment
of evil because he had like some kind of
supernatural sort of [ __ ] to it but in a
real low-key kind of way and to me
that's way scarier don't explain that
[ __ ] just
let it be the way it is
and
i don't want to see mike i was like oh
he's some poor kid that got beat up by
his stripper drug addicted mom or whatev
whatever it's like it just made me so
mad i'm like do you know nothing about
horror at all and like i said there's i
don't have a problem with
torture porn type stuff i don't you know
i'm not one of those people like i love
all kind of horror and depending on what
kind of mood i'm in
um i like real gory [ __ ] i like torture
porn [ __ ] i like all that kind of stuff
it's not my favorite
but
i mean usually i like more ambiguous or
like ghost story type stuff
but if i'm in the mood for like a big
[ __ ] gorfest then yeah i'll watch
that and i'll have a really good time
with it but
don't take a character that was
intriguing because he was mysterious and
demystify him by saying oh he was just
some poor kid that got beat up and then
he turned into a murderer that's just
like
that's just so mundane
you know it's and it's just like takes
away a lot of the intrigue for me i
guess so it kind of ruined it
[Laughter]
kind of ruined it
uh let's see i go sorry i got way behind
i was way behind because i try i try to
answer questions like as they come in
but then like there's so much stuff and
i'm like getting way behind
uh zach says something i'm noticing
lately is movies look too dark in
theaters because they turn the
projective brightness down so they don't
have to replace bulbs as much
i had not noticed that
uh we haven't been to the movies all
that much lately i think like you know
we went and saw dune and we went and saw
like some other stuff but and we went on
nightmare alley which oh nightmare alley
is on hulu already
so if you haven't seen it i i know that
it got like mixed reviews um and i think
it got nominated for an oscar though but
i [ __ ] loved nightmare alley i
thought it was fantastic um and seeing
it come up on hulu i was almost kind of
like man i was kind of watching to want
to watch it again but i don't know we'll
see
uh let's see do do do do do
let's just keep about how's picture
keeps changing colors yeah what happened
was
yesterday when i was uh rearranging
stuff
i had to unplug some of the lights
to you know move them
and sometimes when you unplug the light
and plug it back in it remembers your
settings
sometimes when you unplug it and plug it
back in it doesn't remember your
settings and decides that it's going to
like just change colors randomly and i'm
not entirely sure
how to get it to stop doing that
so
so i'm just like in here working i'm
like oh it's like cycling through all
the colors okay that was like i don't
really know how to fix it so i'm just
gonna leave it like that i mean maybe
tom remembers but i don't and honestly
like they it has remote controls but
they're not within reach at the moment
uh let's see yeah tom's ego is six foot
uh get out and us we're really good yeah
i agree with that uh i really like those
actually i think we saw us twice in the
theater now that i'm thinking about it i
really like that
um
guillermo del toro always worth watching
oh definitely he definitely is you know
what i still haven't seen the shape of
water
but
i think it's on hulu so it's it's on my
list i can't believe that i still
haven't seen that and eventually one day
i want to do a retrospective
um or flickers of fear on chronos
because i actually have it on dvd
in here
and it's really really good if you
haven't said it's one of his very early
movies
i know right
[Laughter]
just needs to pay his water bill
that's right that's right i said [ __ ]
needs to pay his water bill he needs to
pay his water bill why because i saw the
water man going to turn his water off
did he really yeah
oh he must have paid that [ __ ] and
turned it back on though
so they're over there like they can't
have
but i saw the water man turn this
[ __ ] water off they're not worried
about it man they're just like
is that those are the same neighbors
that weren't well hey yeah cookie just
ran into the chair folks um
they were the same neighbors that were
having the super bowl party yeah they
were like the super bowl party that were
blaring uh [ __ ]
fleetwood mac into my window all day
which i'm not a versatility with mac
they're a good band and everything but i
was just kind of like holy crap if i
were to listen to fleetwood mac i'd
listen to fleetwood back in here i don't
need you guys like [ __ ] yeah
like i said you can't
you can't uh give rednecks money you
can't give those [ __ ] money
they'll just ask rick james
james
yeah there's no there's
the color doesn't matter [ __ ] you
can't give a [ __ ] can't give a
redneck [ __ ] money
[ __ ] no they'll just buy bigger speakers
and a bigger truck
[ __ ] your couch and more beer yeah
and all the neighbors yeah well you see
okay
this is what when i used to live in
daytona
my next-door neighbor i can't remember
what his name was
my next-door neighbor was the world's
biggest leonard skinner fan and i'm like
not even joking
and he would get up early and do he had
all this crazy like landscaping [ __ ]
going on in this yard
and like a lot of it was paved but then
he had like all this i don't know what
the hell he was doing over there
so he would get up really early every
morning and the leonard skynyrd would
start blasting about 7 7 30 a.m
which was problematic for me because at
that time i was working on the night
shift so i actually didn't get home
until three or four in the morning
and so i was trying to sleep you know
until at least nine or ten
uh but that never worked out because he
was always out there blasting sweet home
alabama pretty much every day yeah top
of the volume and then
if that wasn't bad enough he would also
sing along
with it at the top of his voice
and
my bedroom was right there like right
next to where he was so
yeah i didn't get a lot of sleep
when i was living there this is what i'm
saying
can't give rednecks money they'll just
use it to make more noise
[Laughter]
let's go down to the biker bar you'll
see it's just on the road
[ __ ] i know like i said i grew
up in daytona motherfucker's money
they're going to put sweet home out of
the bag
over and over and over again it's gonna
be sweet home alabama [ __ ] jenny and
i were laughing we were going down to
mannequins one time and and [ __ ]
everybody was out
and i'm on the car
and
i think our window was cracked and we
were playing just regular [ __ ] like
cold wave you know it might on our ship
probably like for all i know it was
probably like some involved joy division
or something yeah i think it was like
more 80s like we're listening like joy
division yeah and we're getting ready to
pull into the mannequins [ __ ]
intersection where i'm going to go
behind there and get into the damn
parking lot
and a car comes in the on company out of
the crowd there's crowd of people
walking on
on the sidewalks and a car comes at me
and i can hear the [ __ ] bass and the
[ __ ] music and [ __ ] coming out in his
sweet home alabama we laughed and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] was loud as
[ __ ]
and i'm looking and i'm looking i'm
going
who's this [ __ ] banging [ __ ]
sweet home alabama
and it's a brother it's a [ __ ] black
dude
and my mind was [ __ ] blown i don't
know if he was trolling those people or
if he was actually i think maybe
trolling he might have been i think he
was trolling him it was a good troll
because i was trolled i was like what
what the [ __ ]
because how funny would that be i mean i
get it it is pretty funny i laughed it
was [ __ ] fun
my mind was bent i mean i'm like is he
trolling could it be because you never
can't tell this is florida yeah he might
love [ __ ]
you know
that's true i mean i love that [ __ ] you
know what i mean
but it would that would have been a
really good way to troll all those white
people
that too it had been awesome [ __ ]
funny because like i said i think he was
trolling i mean we did laugh i think it
was true it worked it worked but how did
he pull how did he pull a [ __ ] sweet
home alabama out of his ass so quickly
to troll everybody
uh it's called like the 21st century you
can basically just go on [ __ ] spotify
or whatever
i guess uh sure
he was prepared he came prepared
maybe he was playing in the [ __ ] i don't
know i'm gonna drive in downtown sanford
which is like the whitest [ __ ] thing
ever with [ __ ] i mean it's not the
whitest thing ever but it's pretty white
yeah downtown sanford is pretty white
chantal's pissed and she was pissed that
it was getting gentrified and [ __ ]
you know
too many down white people
well i mean her like her business and
all soul food yeah and will was like no
no no no no
okay you know will's was a friend of
mine he's army buddy he's a black guy
and he's uh he's married to an army
major white girl and [ __ ]
will will has some uh some scottish
blood in him but if you were to ask
[ __ ] will he is 100 scottish that
[ __ ] shows up
in a gothed out [ __ ] scottish [ __ ]
kilt yep
uh with a [ __ ] chile or a [ __ ]
well that's irish yeah you know with a
[ __ ] walking cane yeah
that's two different [ __ ] and
drinking drinking single malt scotch
whiskey and [ __ ] he's getting he
likes bagpipe music and [ __ ] you know
he's [ __ ] aunt gotham he goes to the
highland game goes like highland games
and all that you know
and uh he didn't want to hear any of
that he's like oh no you have to have
white people that's where the money's
coming from you know she's like you need
paying clientele in here they love you
chantel [ __ ] this is that this is who
your customers are which that made a lot
of sense to me but that didn't really
seem to make sense to her but you know
i think it did but she was yeah she was
just trolling him i guess
but yeah i mean you know down it's
downtown sanford is i mean it's
we call it downtown it's not
it's very small yeah but it's cool it
has like some cool like if you go down
there's some really good restaurants
there's a lot of german restaurants for
somebody yeah a lot of german
restaurants there's some good there's a
really good used bookstore it's like a
little slash record store it's like all
books downstairs and all like vinyl
upstairs and it's really really nice
it's like a little shirt it's like a
little miniature new orleans french
quarter
yes except it's german
partially large it's largely german yeah
they're in a couple square blocks there
are i believe three german restaurants
maybe more
and a german
there's a german restaurant that's
attached to like a german grocery store
yeah and then there's a soul food
restaurant and a nigerian restaurant yes
and then and a lot of bars right and a
lot of bars and bars and sports bars
about yeah
and uh big tom friend of mine owns the
[ __ ] goth club and he's a black goth
dude which i showed pictures of him he's
a big old [ __ ] six foot
one
black goth dude married to a puerto
rican girl
who has this they're into like new like
80s new waves yeah we met them at ibog
years and years and years ago saturday
nights which is 80s night and he's got
two sons
from his first marriage
and i think they're anglo i think their
first wife was anglo-american you know
they're all white to me his sons to me
they're just like white guys if you ask
me and they're and they're married to
asian girls
well one of them is
yeah they both they both work at
mannequins yeah they all work there
they're all good people it's a good
family
yeah they're super and uh they're super
nice yeah and [ __ ] and and overnight
within a matter of a [ __ ] year or two
tom [ __ ] big tom made a a legendary
nightclub it's known all the way out to
here
all the [ __ ] bartenders know it here
oh mannequins yeah we've heard of that
place you know they all know it
uh it's like a favorite from around here
well as i said there was kicks out there
was nothing like that nothing like it
right
um in downtown sanford for sure downtown
sanford there's a lot of restaurants and
bars and like i said i've been to a
couple of the german restaurants down
there i've been to some of the other
stuff there's like some nice cool like
coffee shops and [ __ ] um so there's some
cool [ __ ] down there but
all of the bars down there are more like
sports bar yeah type things uh sort of
conventional yeah like it's kind of like
bro stuff you're right yeah um so the
fact that big tom
opened
essentially a horror themed
bar
um that play he plays different things
depending on they do like a karaoke
night they do like different themes
but mostly
they do goth industrial
new wave
that kind of some more alternative type
stuff
and it seems to be like really
successful i mean
whenever we go it's usually super packed
like sometimes like i said you get kind
of like the bro kind of crowd in there
because that's kind of who hangs out in
sanford and it's annoying yeah but
people do really seem to be into it yeah
i mean because like i said there's
nothing else like that in that area yeah
if you're downtown orlando you know you
have eyebar slash barbarella which is
actually moving
but
you know i think it's gonna move down
there if you ask me it might i'm not
sure like john is keeping it uh
real hush-hush i got a feeling i got a
feeling tom and john are [ __ ] getting
together or him and scotty might be here
because i kind of feel like they might
be moving it yeah
i that was the first thing i thought too
when i read the interview with him and
he's like oh we're moving and it's 13
miles from our old location it's
stanford and i was kind of like i wonder
is he moving it to stanford like right
by a mannequin that's because it's
territory yeah well and the thing too is
that you're going to get all the people
that are doing like pub crawl type
situations so it's going to like if
people come to mannequins they're going
to go to that place and it's like
they'll you know they'll hit both places
like on friday night or saturday night
and that might be a good thing to do
tina was laughing it would i said she
goes maybe brother just like the beat
it's easy to dance too yeah i don't i'm
going to give him props either way if he
was trolling that's a [ __ ] great
troll if he actually liked that okay
i see a brother in a decked out white
cadillac [ __ ] bumping [ __ ] sweet
home alabama
i'm gonna think troll
that's all they troll although but it
was a good one here's the thing he
didn't have the troll look on his face
though he was he was he was about my age
and he was just me okay and he was just
rolling serious like
yeah no he he cause that's the thing i
kind of feel like maybe but it was a
good troll
younger generation
um
leonard skinner might not have the same
stigma yeah maybe that it has two people
of our era but he was looked to be maybe
well okay he might have been younger
than me he might be about 40. that's
what i'm saying so it's like maybe it
didn't occur to him that this was like a
weird thing for him to be listening to
yeah or not or maybe he did but not to
the degree that we would
see it as i mean to me
like i said that seems like a troll yeah
but i don't know you know i don't know
that dude's life so yeah murder hornets
asked me if i've noticed any acne taking
tests uh no not at not at 200 milligrams
i don't i didn't i didn't get any uh
maybe like maybe one or two but it'd be
like in a weird spot like on a shoulder
or something
but no i didn't notice anything now
start throwing in other stuff
a little bit but the thing is is i don't
do anything aggressive you know i've
looked at what some of these guys are
taking i'm like man that's a [ __ ] lot
and they'll take a lot in a couple
months period and then they'll jump off
and i'm like
dude i'm like man you weigh 190 pounds
and you're taking that
that's kind of like what a guy 240
pounds 250 pounds ought to be taken you
know and they kind of go through
i don't know i haven't seen what you're
talking about murder hornets i mean yeah
you might if you're getting an
occasional [ __ ] red bump here or
there
i have to see what extent you're talking
about because he says he's getting some
stuff you don't take that much as far as
i know i mean i you know
i don't know how much you're taking
but test is
test is not to be used as an anabolic
it's a base
for maintenance
you can take anabolics once you're on
that
you have to take everything at once
because antibiotics will [ __ ] shut
down testosterone production
in a young male
well if you're old if you're our age
you're taking you're taking exogenous
testosterone anyway there's
there's nothing to be shut down because
you're ejecting it
so since you're taking exogenous
hormones
it's now permission you the gate is open
you can go ahead and take anabolic
substances because it won't shut you
down you're already shut down and you're
injecting the test that you need so
you're layering it in there on a stack
you know
we're old guys we can do that now look
for you younger people listening to me
you got [ __ ] teenage [ __ ] dudes
doing stupid [ __ ] with these [ __ ]
steroids and all this [ __ ] you're too
young to be on all that on all that
stuff you have decent testosterone
production
these dudes like [ __ ] arnold and
these and [ __ ] stallone
they had professional advice
back and with the best advice and the
best stuff that they had back in those
days
and they're lucky to have [ __ ] made
it made it out of that situation
as well as they did because a lot of
guys that they came up with died
they were taking too much and not really
knowing how to come off anything
they would just take some steroids and
come off of them and wonder why they got
fat
they didn't know anything about pct
versus post psychotherapies they didn't
know the repercussions for things
hormones have to be balanced
and the horm and the endocrine system
doesn't like anything that's [ __ ]
abrupt changes
you know
everything has to be [ __ ] gradual and
mellow and
and then another thing is you have to
work out
uh the more you work out the better
results you're gonna get
yeah you can take that [ __ ] and not work
out your body composition will change a
bit
but it's better to work out
you'll you'll get better results
so uh anyway
back to back to what you were asking me
talk to me in private and [ __ ] show
me some photographs of exactly what
you're talking about and i'll tell you
if that's if that's if that's something
you need to worry about or not
zaneta says they make country rap now
tom yeah you're behind the times yeah
well they have they have hip-hop
everything they have hip-hop and
honestly uh grampar says is sweet home
alabama the rock anthem of the south
that'd be free bird uh but sweet home
alabama also by leonard skinner probably
number two on that list and those are
huge old-school biker songs i mean
they have not
got sick of them after what has what has
it been 50 years yeah uh yeah still not
sick of that [ __ ] now the old the
younger bikers my age
aren't really listening to that too much
they're mostly into the [ __ ] like
slipknot weird i was gonna say they're
probably like 90s nine and metal yeah
and metal that he's metal and grunge
yeah yeah
uh danny rowling says uh black people
listen to a lot of white music this
nowadays i kind of feel like they always
did because honestly a lot of hip-hop
which i listen to more of in my teenage
years and my 20s i think that i do now
but
a lot of the samples particularly like
in the 80s and early 90s when they had a
lot of sampling were from
uh pop music from the 70s and 80s
another thing i've been noticing and uh
we have some listeners who fit this
demographic
black girls
gen x and younger
who are metal fans love metal they love
metallica love old maiden and they're
and some of the some of the black girls
that are listening to this
they're like um
in their 20s mid-20s maybe late 20s and
they're listening to like
iron maiden and judas priests from the
70s and the 80s
which that's mind-boggling but they just
[ __ ] see that's what i was saying
before that's why you can't tell right
if
you know like you say you see a black a
black guy driving around listening to
like leonard skinner yeah that might not
be ironic he might actually because it
doesn't have the same stigma i kind of
feel like back in the old days yeah it
was the kind of music that you listened
to was more
compartmentalized yeah it was different
back in our day nowadays it's kind of
like the you know younger people that
didn't grow up with those divisions
um they just hear something and they're
like oh i like that yeah they don't
really think that there's like some
whole like cultural baggage right yeah
about it which honestly i think that's a
good thing probably better i think
that's a good thing right
music from
us being gen x music was part of our
social media oh big time and uh and
you're you're there wasn't a lot of
crossover no not really i mean you're
clicks but we're
very much music oriented
now some metal dudes started to listen
to rap i started i started to like
um a [ __ ] uh public enemy i bought uh
yo bum rush the show their very first
app i like public academy i liked
as well
yeah i saw him live actually iced tea he
was rap but that wasn't gangsta rap not
really i liked [ __ ] public enemy he
did body count though
yeah yeah okay i thought you're talking
i got confused i thought you know what
you said iced tea and i thought vanilla
ice
ice tea was gangster rap and i mean you
know you had that album you know that i
would not have liked vanilla i'm
drinking yeah come on
the uh but [ __ ] for me public enemy
was the best one yeah they [ __ ] love
chuck d and [ __ ] flint and flav and
he putting on his [ __ ] hype man
routine with a [ __ ] clock you know
what time it is you know like because
the clock is to tell you what time it is
you know and all the symbolism and the
[ __ ] uh black nationalism going on in
it and [ __ ] uh you know [ __ ]
references to [ __ ] farrakhan and you
know me being white [ __ ] totally out
of that loop but i understood the spirit
behind it i was like yeah yeah [ __ ] it
right you know what i mean you know just
pull you right into it it was and
another thing that i really liked about
that era of rap is that it was
it was homemade there weren't any
corporations involved it was dudes
making their own music so it was a lot
more authentic
um
as soon as the mainstream music industry
started to get involved and money
started well that happens it's happened
with punk it happened with ev anything
that's like good and like grassroots and
stuff right once like some
money people get involved yeah it's not
quite as good then they start sampling
classic [ __ ] [ __ ] from [ __ ]
from annie you know a musical annie you
know [ __ ] hard knocks life and i'm
going women now this dude from the hood
he does not have that cultural reference
a white dude knew that song that's who
made that music and this and you know
that there's outside input to try to
make a fake product
80s rap
was the best rap if you asked me and
then some of the 90s stuff man [ __ ] i
was a huge fan of cypress hill
i liked it just which is they were also
good yeah yeah and that was that was
chicano rap they were really good now
a rap band came out they were black
dudes and they were from california and
it was an experimental rap
band called new kingdom and i had one of
their albums i [ __ ] loved it it was
called
um
paradise don't come cheap and guess what
it's called paradise don't come cheap i
think it was called and that album is
badass uh if it's probably on youtube
called new kingdom and it was southwest
desert
rap
and there's a bunch of [ __ ]
jimi hendrix
[ __ ]
mixed into it and
harmonica with blues
and gangsta rap and
it was that was for me that was i love
the hybrid [ __ ]
yeah for me that was one of the best rap
bands and total flop nobody liked it
nobody liked it it was experimental but
that's for me that's
for me the two best back rap bands of
all times the public enemy and new
kingdom
i just thought they were great
yeah i don't think i ever heard that
yeah new kingdom was really good
it was desert rap but that sounds
interesting black dudes in the desert
going sway down south across the border
just like jimi hendrix with his heart
with a post
jimi hendrix on a horse with a holster
on his poster [ __ ] yeah you know what
i'm talking about if i can remember that
old poster of [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
i like that i like that they're driving
through the desert in their car you know
and the [ __ ] harmonica going you know
yeah really good you'd like it
you'd like it like i said it said we're
talking about smuggling things from
across the border in the southwest
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
no need for me too thank you very much
check out warren zevon's werewolves of
london yeah we know it
yeah yeah it's the same damn song as
sweet home alabama honestly
yeah
now that you mentioned it warren zevon
had a bunch of good stuff you know what
i mean he did yeah uh my favorite song
that he did was [ __ ] uh rolling the
headless thompson gunner
oh that's a good that's a really good
song that's a good song yeah
[Laughter]
dj maniac says public enemy was an
industrial band with rappers as far as
i'm concerned yeah and i kind of yeah it
was late 80s early 90s that was kind of
like the heyday of the hip-hop
industrial metal crossover
man there was so much of that [ __ ] going
on yeah some of it not so good i will
admit but
a lot of it actually was really good t
she talked about her favorite rap bands
t go ahead and open another window click
over go into youtube and go look for
new kingdom
paradise don't come cheap
and listen to that get back to mike
my creepy phones right again
you would love that
yeah beastie boys were early genre
benders yeah i mean i kind of feel like
i don't know it was just
i
the reason that i still like return
again and again to
mid to late 70s early 80s was because
the whole punk and post-punk era
to me
that was like the last big
thing where everyone was like everything
was on the table you could take anything
and mix it with anything
and
you would find an audience where you
would find a receptive audience maybe
not a massive audience obviously um but
like i said you could mix anything you
could do like [ __ ]
uh you know
just ever i don't know like everything
man you could like [ __ ] take uh you
know look at [ __ ] klaus know me i'm
gonna mix new wave and opera
and it [ __ ] worked you know what i
mean like nowadays well i don't know
maybe you could do that nowadays and
people will be like all right
but nobody had really done that
in that time period
and
that's kind of a little bit what makes
me sad nowadays is that i feel like so
much [ __ ] was done back then
that nowadays people do new [ __ ] and
like mix up stuff and everything but now
you're just kind of like oh well
somebody already did that like in the
70s or 80s so i don't know
i don't know i don't want to be one of
those old people that's like oh
everything's been done because i'm sure
it hasn't but
i do kind of feel like
the late 70s early 80s was kind of like
the last big
creative explosion where people were
fusing things together that hadn't
previously been done so you kind of saw
some [ __ ] that hadn't been done
prior
um
and now everyone's just kind of
going back to that because that was like
such a fertile like creative period
but
as i said you know i i don't like to be
one of those people that's like oh
everything's been done because
will be new things all the time there'll
be new things new technologies that you
can uh you know
manifest in certain ways and we don't
know how that's going to turn out so
you know i don't want to be like that
uh danny rowling says i only like tea's
wife
yeah [ __ ] what's your name coco coco
yeah she's cute yeah
iced tea was iced tea was in that tide
cold commercial just the other day him
and stone cold steve austin and gordon
ramsay
i saw that like i was watching something
on tubie and i'm like they've really got
all these [ __ ] in one [ __ ]
tide commercial good job yeah
but uh yeah so that's the thing like dj
maniac talking about the kind of hip-hop
and uh industrial crossover honestly i
went to the first
lollapalooza
in the night in 1991 was it 1991 yeah
and i went to it in atlanta
and uh the the bands
it was just kind of it was a really
fascinating
time capsule of the time period so i
think the bands were it was the butthole
surfers
it was the rollins band
it was susie and the banshees
living color
jane's addiction
nine inch nails
who the [ __ ] else was on that [ __ ]
uh
god damn it i feel like there were a
couple other bands but i can't remember
it was so hot that day i got like
[ __ ] heat stroke
because they always had that [ __ ] in the
summer
one of the things that i remember i
might have brought this up on the show
before when they had the uh lollapalooza
in 1994 because i went to the first one
in 1991 in atlanta
1994
they announced that they were actually
going to do one in deland florida which
was only about 20 minutes from where i
grew up in daytona and i was so excited
because
on the 1994
roster
was [ __ ]
nick cave and the bad seeds also l7
which i was a big fan of i remember them
and
i was so jazzed i had my [ __ ] tickets
i had everything and i was just kind of
like we had everything packed up me and
my brother and a couple of our other
friends were gonna go
and the morning of the show we woke up
and it had rained overnight and the uh
volusia county fairgrounds where they
were holding it had flooded
and they couldn't set the stage up so
they cancelled it
so that was my one and only time
probably to ever get to see nick cave
live
and
man i'm still not over that and that was
like 1994.
i still haven't seen nick cave live
i think he's the only
no that's not true i was gonna say he's
the only one that i wanted to see live
that i never got to
i never got to see the fall live and i
can't now because marky smith died a
couple years ago
uh never got to see duran duran live
we were gonna go a couple years ago but
it was too [ __ ] expensive
let's see how i was talking about tea
and it's on uh youtube and uh google you
can watch uh songify you can get you can
watch it for free or you can listen
yeah spotify you can you can uh
yeah i thought it said songified you
know like such a
it's for free you can listen to it
that's a [ __ ] absolutely awesome
[ __ ] rap album really good
let's see if i can see what the band
looks like that's what they look like
that was part part of the reason why
they didn't fly is because they were
just
cutting across genres but the
the quality is really good really really
good you're always gonna have a harder
road to hoe when you're
doing crossover genres that don't
normally go together
yeah that's any creative endeavor
whether it's movie making music anything
yeah they're doing they're doing rap
with retro [ __ ] 1960s car racing
motifs and stuff you know like from
bullet
they just they understood all of the
references
so i just thought it was just
culturally just real important
artistically
classic i can't understand why it didn't
work
uh although if you read the comment
sections on that album in youtube people
are talking about
what a masterpiece that album is and how
stupid people are
well like i said it's a it's a lot of
things it's always about timing and it's
always about marketing it's always about
a lot of things
well i mean we've talked about that on
some of our movie review shows sometimes
you'll see a movie and i'm like god damn
that was like brilliant and yeah
for whatever reason it just didn't hit
at the right time or didn't like they
didn't market it right or something it
was experimental and it was ahead of its
time
and uh and it was brilliant
and for some reason the market wanted
something dumber
zack says can we also appreciate the
fact that ice t is a really good actor
too yeah he is he is actually well uh
he's he's uh
kind of a um
a genius in a lot of ways
he knows how you know he knows how to
manage himself
his image on television well you know
he's kind of from another era but
he's a good he's a good dude he's he's
entertaining everybody likes him i mean
i had uh i never got to meet him i saw
him live a few times but i never got to
meet him but i have a friend that met
him and talked to him extensively and
said he was like a super super nice dude
so yeah
uh yeah tila is bringing up living color
i honestly live in colorado they were
good they were fantastic live too
fantastic they were good metals i saw
them at lollapalooza uh no need for me
too says never really got into fishbone
i actually quite like fishbone uh they
weren't my favorite but yeah cheryl says
i love henry rollins i could talk listen
to him talk forever yeah henry rollins
uh very cool he's in a lot of movies too
not an actor but he's kind of like a
personality that's i guess like flea
like flea turns up in a lot of movies
too but uh yeah
let's see dude so t says she added that
one yeah you're gonna like that one t
yeah
think southwest
all right
dudes out in the desert that's their new
kingdom from what they're saying they've
moved out into the [ __ ] southwest
desert
and uh that's just the motif of that
album and
survival in the desert and
i feel like every sub-genre has its
desert sub-sub-genre
even goth has that look at like fields
of the nephilim and [ __ ]
it's like hey we're all dressing up like
dusty ass cowboys dusty cowboys
surviving the [ __ ] south desert in
the wasteland in the wasteland right
here
uh thank you again tila favorite albums
of all times y'all oh [ __ ] well you can
grab that one right there jen
this one right here first and last night
oh look i have this on final [ __ ]
yeah on final
this is tom's favorite albums of all
times
that is the best album ever made
it's by the sisters of mercy and not all
their albums are good some other albums
i don't like at all i mean they don't
have a lot uh yeah but this is
this this album is the best album ever
made and most people don't know it and
that there there's the sisters all right
um and another thing that's weird
does it have the inner jacket oh you
don't have the original inner jacket
the original enter jacket would show uh
was right outside uh san andreas hall in
in detroit yeah where it said detroit's
famous
i'm not sure what year that's from
that's the best album
that's the best album that's ever been
made uh
and now
oh [ __ ] yeah
you messed it up t you would like that
album too called the
sisters of mercy first and last and
always oh [ __ ] get up there and yeah
[ __ ] fix that
i had all this like i said i was
rearranging stuff and it it stayed until
we
just leave it like that no okay oh it's
gonna slide yeah yeah
i've had people
private direct message me
over the years
people who don't know anything about
goth music
direct message me saying tom i listen to
that album and i can't stop listening to
that i mean it's just a good run like
because you are right that is the best
album ever [ __ ] made if you play that
[ __ ] in a car
that's it you're gonna be playing that
[ __ ] in a car for [ __ ] years
that album
was just the best album ever made
and now after that there's a bunch of
other ones that are
the best
for different reasons
some of them are just artistic reasons
like there's some prog rock albums out
there that are just like man that's a
[ __ ] badass i'm like dark side of the
moon but anybody knows that one i like
metal too there's some pink floyd
dark side of the moon pink floyd metal
or metally i think it's metal metal i
think is what it's called
um
or echoes that's what it was called
echoes his name that album had the whale
song in it
those are both two real good albums um
but there's so much good stuff you know
that's what i mean it's almost kind of
like if i ever had to pick like my top
fen 10 favorite albums i'd be [ __ ]
screwed that would just be like trying
to pick my top 10 favorite movies yeah
john goris says michael jackson's
thriller sorry not sorry don't be sorry
that's a good album yeah
it's probably one of the best pop albums
of all times
cheryl has some good picks uh operation
ivy debut tools lateralis bauhaus mask
that's what yes that would also be in my
opinion it's a real good one uh
nightingale it's downward spiral another
good one uh bowie station to station
yeah
low is my favorite but station to
station i like stations [ __ ] awesome
too the return of the thin white duke
throwing darts in lovers eyes that's it
and she also chooses michael jackson
throughout like i said that's a good
all-around album i didn't like it at the
time it came out but i appreciated it
later i think when i wasn't such a like
a cranky little goth teen
i got more into stuff i don't know
god
okay
joy division closer closer
yeah i mean that that that album is just
like a whole that's a whole world it's a
whole world
itself
where you just go into it it's like this
wintry bleak
i just love the whole vibe of that i
love the whole man i put in i would put
on closer in
in boston
in this in the winter when it was
snowing on the car radio and that [ __ ]
made so much [ __ ] sense man
and like i said i read somewhere a very
long time ago when i was a teenager and
they said this is the best album to
listen to with no other sensory stimuli
yeah like no light no other sound no
anything and so i of course i did that
one time i blacked out the curtains and
like listened to it just like without
any other
uh distractions and it was just kind of
like it sends you to like another place
man like i said it's like a whole it's a
whole vibe yeah it's a whole thing i'm
gonna show the art the album cover art
for closer
if you guys this is definitely [ __ ] man
also gotta say some of my other i'm
trying to think of my other favorites i
mean closer is probably my favorite
that's what the cover of closer looks
like
it's funerary art
all right and that's from savannah
georgia isn't it
uh yeah
actually there's a famous uh my friend
melissa went and took a bunch of
pictures of her goth out pictures in
that cemetery it's in savannah georgia
but the closer album cover
let me see
there that's what the that's what the
cover looks like it's got a border
around it
get get focus
focus
well
you're messing up the layers it just
says closer
all right i have that font on my
computer now that it's called jd closer
right
so first and last and always and joy
division closer
man that's a good album spooky
still
cold sounding album with
lyrics that are real deep it sounds like
this ancient old man telling you this
wisdom from across the ages
of the sorrows of the world and the
suffering
you find out this is a [ __ ] 19 year
old kid [ __ ] singing this to you well
i mean i think he was 20 22 22 maybe but
he just well he died when he was 23.
yeah he died himself afterwards but
uh he just before that even came out
he's just real
epic
you know
real epic which is funny because if you
know anything about their history
um
in person he was nothing like that like
you wouldn't suspect like he was just a
regular bloke as they would say in the
uk you know he just hung out and drank
and made jokes and [ __ ] like that like a
regular dude but when he sang he sounded
like [ __ ]
i don't even know what the [ __ ] he
sounded like he was channeling like some
[ __ ] ancient wisdom from somewhere i
don't know
yeah i don't know what the [ __ ] that was
always standing back looking at it
looking at these looking at the weird
[ __ ] the way the life is
where are the young men the weight on
their shoulders
i do love that record that's probably i
mean honestly probably my favorite like
i said i'm into bauhaus too mask is my
favorite just because it's so diverse i
like that they experimented with
um you know they did goth they did metal
they did reggae they did all but it all
kind of like works together and i think
that was good i like their other albums
too but they're a little more hit or
miss
um
yeah i got to give some love to ekko and
the bunnymen yeah ocean rain yeah i
[ __ ] love that album i think i
played it so many times i had it on
vinyl and i played it so many times that
it wore out so i bought it again graham
says steve ross friend of ours we went
to high school introduced me to metal
whenever i hear fearless i think of old
times yeah and then uh [ __ ] song
echoes with the whale song it's a whole
side of a whole album pink floyd album
that's a great album
and then samus
talking about the dog the dog that's
outside samus that's just a good album
is it epic yes epic in the prague rock
sense
but for me so far i've put at the top
five
first and last and always enjoy the from
sisters of mercy
joy divisions closer
uh
i return to that one i think more than
any other album
and after that would probably be a suzy
album something probably kind of like
i like tinderbox tinderbox but
i know that's maybe not the consensus
right but tinderbox is my favorite
of theirs yeah a little not all the
songs on it are great though
uh some of them are kind of it's good
album though
what if it was something more along the
lines of uh number three probably i mean
juju also great
there was some switchblade albums that
were [ __ ] great epic album but uh but
they're not
they're kind of forgotten
like what was the uh
what was that [ __ ]
switchblade album that had the damn trip
hop sound to
i think it was their last album
i can't remember i only had a couple of
puppets or tea and
i forgot i only had a couple other older
ones yeah yeah um
[ __ ] but those first two are solid
though what would number three be
i don't know
mask
i mean yeah i already said that that
would that would be number three
well what are you asking me for this is
your favorites
don't be that way
well i don't know what i'm trying to say
number three we're trying to think what
the third best album would be
what would come next
well i'm gonna say and mega just uh said
the grinder band albums are great yes
they are
um
and honestly like like i said another
album i return to a lot and
because you guys know i love uh nick
cave right i love nick cave i love the
birthday party i love grindr man
if i had to pick a favorite nick cave
album
i don't think i could uh because it
depends on whatever mood i'm in
usually
um
[Music]
it's either
from here to eternity from her to
eternity rather or
henry's dream
or sometimes let love in it depends on
what kind of mood i'm in if i'm in a
more bluesy mood than firstborn is dead
but you know what i mean um
so there's that and birthday party i'm
gonna say
the mutiny
ep
not a lot of songs on it but they're all
amazing
so
oh there's that
all right then me and jenny are gonna
kind of [ __ ] hold on we're going to
kind of
diverge well like i said we're not going
to come up with the same it's not going
to be the same yeah because i like some
different [ __ ] to what you like
i mean we like a lot of the same stuff
my no but you're not real into nick cave
and i am yeah i'm not really into that
my third my
third
favorite album i'm gonna show you guys
the [ __ ] album cover
okay
the third favorite album after the other
two
is this one
oh [ __ ] what these [ __ ]
okay
the hell
i don't know all right
this one right here
number three would be
judas priest
sad wings of destiny
which is a 1970s metal album
that is one of the best [ __ ] albums
ever it's great it's a really good album
thank you again tila
okay here's the last one she says name a
song or group that people will be
surprised that you really love be honest
y'all
so many
um
oh man okay i like
a lot of 50s rockabilly
i particularly like uh
jerry lee lewis
uh so there's that i like a lot of elvis
i like roy orbison i like that kind of
stuff
i like a lot of
show tunes
i like a lot of
70s disco
honestly
somebody mentioned amy winehouse i
[ __ ] love amy winehouse she's rad
um i have a couple of her albums
actually
so
i'm not real like i said i'm normally
i'm a very you know 80s post punk
not just 80s but i like any kind of that
anything that has like that post punk
sound to it
and i like a lot of you know just
regular punk as well from the old days
and new [ __ ] although i don't really
like the pop punk thing so much
that's that's not really my thing i do
like some of it but most of it's kind of
in
but
honestly anything that's good i don't
know i like a lot of stuff that's kind
of like
i even like weird [ __ ] like tom jones
and stuff like that i like stuff that's
like theatrical
you know that's why i like kind of like
show tunes and stuff
i'm into that kind of stuff yeah
anything that's kind of like over the
top and like
you know as long as it's not too
schmalty cheryl's making fun of the tom
of course would pick judas priest no
i'm a huge um
i mean he i like i like good judas
priest not all judas priests was great
um set some of the 70s stuff some of the
80s stuff some of the 90s stuff
some of the newer stuff but not not all
of it there's it's just like anything
else there's there's a lot of hit and
miss you know i mean but rob halford
he's [ __ ] great uh he's god metal god
you know he actually trademarked that
name
[ __ ]
sophie was down there watching him live
sending me [ __ ]
[ __ ] clips from his show and he's
like man this was awesome and i said
well of course that's god what do you
mean because people call him god
metal god and she checked it out and
because yeah his
rob halford's [ __ ] nickname is god
yeah a metal god tm yeah metal god
[Laughter]
[ __ ] can sing and even though
he's in his 70s doing it down fred g
sanford [ __ ] moves because he can't
dance like dummy
he can't dance anymore you know but he
can [ __ ] still sing he's old give him
a break send him something he's freaking
great
and he [ __ ] loves the crowd that they
come to see
but uh t
check out those three albums right there
check out [ __ ]
check out uh check out sad wings of
destiny i think that was 1972 or 73
and just a [ __ ] a lot of soul in
those albums a lot of [ __ ]
metal soul
um real good
but um
yeah
what was your last question
talking about uh a song or group that
you will be surprised okay all right i
can answer that
well i have so many things
one that people probably wouldn't think
i i [ __ ] love i'm a huge fan of
bananarama i [ __ ] love banana british
called bananarama that was like the
original [ __ ] british girl band
banana awesome but unlike a [ __ ]
menudo and [ __ ] like that bananarama
were kind of self-made
they made those songs and those dance
routines and that was real low budget
when it started um
by the time the late 80s came around you
know they did a really good good cover
of [ __ ] venus you know oh my god i
love that yeah
i love these cute [ __ ] british girls
and [ __ ] singing and dancing but i
really know i'm more from like the era
of [ __ ] you know robert de niro's
waiting that's [ __ ] good song like
that and [ __ ] what was uh cruel
summer is the [ __ ] great song yeah
cruel summer yeah that's a great song
and uh yeah all their old stuff you know
john gore says i love me some one-hit
wonders like spandau ballet's true
that's a good song honestly a lot the
80s i kind of feel like that was the
golden era of the one-hit wonder
although a lot of them were just one hit
wonders in the u.s because i do kind of
feel like sometimes like okay for
example
in the u.s people would consider gary
newman's cars that's like his one-hit
wonder because that was like a big
success but in the uk he had like a
bunch of other hits and if you're in the
goth scene he's still going and he has
like a lot of really good albums
but
yeah all that stuff like [ __ ] nina 99
red balloons i love that [ __ ] song
like all the 80s like one hit wonders
yeah like [ __ ] great i love all that
dexie's midnight runners all that kind
of stuff he was like what what what have
bananas saying and face cruel summer
added to the playlist yeah
see venus
watch yeah which is a cover but it's a
good cover though venus is good uh what
else did they did they did um
um what's that other [ __ ] oh they had
more than that i'm gonna look real quick
yeah look it up because i can't remember
cruel summer was actually off their
second album i think yeah that was like
an older one and then they caught got a
little bit more successful later on
but
uh yeah d i think dj maniac said abba
yeah i'm i'm kind of i like i like abba
honestly
um when i was a kid i was really into
that song sos i did like a whole dance
routine to it
and everything
annie lennox some people are bringing up
yeah
they did i heard a rumor oh that's right
yeah yeah the head did uh
na na hey hey kiss him goodbye that's
also a cover yeah but that was good too
it did love the first degree remember
that oh yeah i remember that one okay
they did they had a lot of hits and a
lot of they did actually um
cheryl says i love that song walk like
an egyptian from the 80s who was that
that was the bangles actually yeah why
did i remember i remember every [ __ ]
thing from the 80s i was from well i was
watching a lot of mtv at times those are
bengals yeah the bengals had some great
songs too to be honest with you i didn't
walk like an egyptian i liked it at the
time i liked it less later but
they um
didn't they they did uh
manic monday although prince wrote that
did he not
i'm pretty sure prince wrote that song
that was bananarama what what [ __ ]
maybe 82 with all their little overalls
yeah the overall
cars yeah
yeah that was them
they were a good band they were kind of
like the girlfriends to a lot of uh i
think one of them okay have you ever
seen the uh
the video um come on eileen from dexter
exists midnight midnight runners the
girl that he's singing to is siobhan
fahey's sister yeah siobhan was
one of the girls well did not they they
like knew each other well didn't they
shoot off into like uh shakespeare's
sister
siobhan left and then and ended up and
they had a band called shakespeare which
was named after a smith song yeah
actually right
which i think that was another album i
forgot to mention as much as morrissey
like turned into a douche into his old
age but
i still love the smiths
uh queen is dead probably my favorite
but again it depends on what mood i'm in
some days i'm like oh i really like the
first album the best some days i really
like meet his murder the best queen is
dead i think is the most consistently
good
but
like i said it's like nick cave albums
they're all good and it's kind of like
it just depends on whatever mood you
you're
shakespeare's sister actually came out
with a new album and they they still
[ __ ]
look great
look great they're in their 60s by now
easily yeah they got to be like that age
at least well they were older than us
yeah they were older when they were
banned without
seventies so they're probably like
[ __ ] world yeah so probably like our
parents age
they might be 70s which is crazy but
that's
you might want to see shakespeare's
sister the [ __ ] video and called stay
and then uh yeah
yeah that was uh
mid 90s maybe about 94 i think
might have been earlier
then maybe a little bit earlier maybe
earlier that's a good album i have it
and then [ __ ] siobhan shows up as the
[ __ ] spirit of death and [ __ ] and
starts singing crazy [ __ ] let me see
our internet's kind of slow because of
the connections
there he is then siobhan shows up
doing her thing
i think that might have been 93
yeah
yeah
danny rowling brings up taco uh putting
on the wrist yeah yeah i remember that
one yeah that was another one hit wonder
there were a lot in the 80s that were
actually really good
do you know what i don't know why i just
thought of this one
do you remember the song
jeopardy
by greg kin band
i remember really being into that video
because i mean it's super super cheap
they made it for like ten dollars but it
was like
a monster movie kinda
but a really really cheap one but
i don't know like i was kind of like
into it it's a good song
i think like it was uh popular enough
that weird al even did a parody of it
about the game show jeopardy
even the original song was just
not about the game show
it was just about being in danger in
general
safety dance uh i still unequivocally
and unashamedly love that song so sorry
i i do
honestly and somebody says wham
honestly uh i also unironically love
wham
if they
uh if they play wham like [ __ ] uh
wake me up before you go go or some [ __ ]
at like [ __ ]
eyebar i'm totally dancing to that i i
mean if i'm a little bit inebriated i
will totally dance to that it's a good
song
that's a good song so i kind of feel
like
and i think i brought this up before a
few years ago
there was a commercial
and i can't remember what the commercial
was for it might have been for like
light dark or something something for
washing black clothes
and there was or no i think it was for a
beer actually like a dark beer maybe
yeah you're talking about and what oh no
they're talking about [ __ ] banana
ramen mila jojovic was
her bad was shakespeare's sister and
everything and
tina's [ __ ]
saving that you would like it
uh uh tila
shakespeare's sister was very like happy
and upbeat and um kind of uh but it was
also kind of had a kind of an
underground
vibe to it it was it was a good mix
they did do mainstream [ __ ]
but it was kind of like punk rock girls
in a certain way doing it sorry uh john
goris just brought up weird al and i was
just kind of like i thought i would make
another drink i thought i would uh
put that that's that's right here in my
in my little album collection
i'm going here i'm like scared to move
them because i moved it before and it
just like all fell over like i said i
just rearranged in here the other day
but um yeah so
yeah so there was a commercial
and i loved it because uh it showed like
the outside of a goth club and there
were all these like really grouchy
looking gods as you would you know you
stand out waiting in line and be like
[ __ ] off
so everybody's like looking all pissed
off
and like some bro people are like walk
by and they're just like when we want to
go in here everybody looks like they're
all like dour and [ __ ] and then they
show the inside of the goth club and
that's playing wham's wake me up before
you go go and all the gods are like
dancing and they're like happy and stuff
i'm like accurate that's accurate and
it's just like the first time i saw a
commercial i just laughed and laughed
and laughed i was like somebody like me
made this commercial
it's like [ __ ] funny
oh my god
yeah so we're talking yeah we're talking
about uh
jeopardy
thank you i'm a big fan of weird al to
be honest i had i have dared be stupid i
had um weirdo yankovic in 3d
which had because i don't know if people
know but weird al
he also i mean he did his uh parody
songs which were hilarious but he also
did a lot of uh originals
my favorite of those i think was on
weird al uh in 3d and it was called
nature trail to hell
and it was like
it was a song about a trailer about a
slasher movie about a bunch of boy
scouts who go to a camp and then get
murdered one by one and it was
hysterical i still remember that [ __ ]
song i might still have that album over
here somewhere well like i said i'm kind
of like afraid to pull him out because
everything's gonna [ __ ] fall down
uh no need for me too it's like frankie
two tribes video oh yeah i remember that
one yeah frankie goes to hollywood
that's another one the song relax i
actually still have that on my phone
and we'll listen to it sometimes when
i'm working out same with uh pop music
by m i really really like that song like
again not ashamed i have that on my
phone also i'm trying to think of like
all the 80s ones that i have on my phone
uh my sharona pretty sure that's on
there by the name
i like a lot of those [ __ ] cheesy ass
80s songs i really do
and i like them more now that i'm older
like i liked him at the time but i was
kind of more into
i mean you know in the 80s i was really
into like duran duran and then i got
into like joy division and the smiths
and depeche mode and
you know bauhaus and alien sex fiend and
stuff and so the new wave stuff like
went a little bit on the back burner but
i still like really did like a lot of
that stuff and honestly like the older i
get the more i was like man that was a
good [ __ ] song
uh noting it for me too says i have over
30 gigs of music on my phone yeah
um the weirdo goth song
i want to hear nick cave cover that one
he bite he covered uh
what was that song by pulp
was it called disco 2000 or whatever
nick cave did a cover of that which was
pretty hilarious
i have that somewhere
on my phone also
he does honestly i don't know if you
guys know but uh nick cave did two songs
on this what the [ __ ] was the name of
that album i don't have the whole album
i just have his uh songs off of it but
it was a whole album of different bands
covering
pirate sea shanties
because the second i saw that and then i
was like oh nick cave's got to be on the
oh of course nick cave did two songs on
there he did pinery boy
and
uh fire down below
and i got both of those songs and
they're both
amazing amazing another band these
[ __ ] have forgotten
that i liked that i'd probably [ __ ]
say like nobody would ever think i'd
like them because i [ __ ] liked army
of lovers
oh yeah every time that comes on it yeah
the [ __ ] love he's like yeah yeah
yeah
it's the gayest [ __ ] of all time it is
the gas [ __ ] of us
yeah crucified yes
t
go [ __ ] go
put that on your list army of lovers
crucified and the video is [ __ ] off a
chain i've had a couple there it's
pretty great i guess it's pretty great i
had a couple of their albums they didn't
make great albums but they did make
great videos and good songs some of the
songs were good on them but the albums
weren't that good but [ __ ]
army of lovers was the [ __ ] they were
from sweden
sweden or was it denmark i think it was
sweden i can't yeah somewhere and it was
kind of
techno
kind of poppy
and
and it had kind of i'm going to show you
i'm going to show you
yeah don't get it demonetized but yeah
yeah yeah
okay
djm8x says common people yeah i actually
i like the pulp version of common people
but that wasn't the one that cave
covered i think it was disco 2000 okay
cheryl also says unpopular opinion i
really don't like metallica i'm not a
huge fan of metallica either gotta say
they don't really seem all that
distinctive to me i don't maybe that's
just when they first appeared what yeah
they were then
but then i was just kind of like
for the first
for the beginning part of their
career
they ended up kind of being
commercial
yeah and i think that was kind of when
dj maniac says oh army of lovers crucify
video got me through my teenage years
yeah that is a great video that is such
an army of lovers
looking it is gay as [ __ ] but like but
it is [ __ ] awesome
it's like an epic that's like camilla
yeah
i'm crucified
crucified like my savior and i i could
dance like a crack when that [ __ ] comes
on and i'm [ __ ] yeah
i start [ __ ] dancing like that and it
just man the energy starts [ __ ]
flying and the video is not that great
but the song is [ __ ] really good
yeah
what's that other song that you like
that i can't stand that french one oh um
[ __ ]
yeah
god
yeah
um
sorry i saw something else that i wanted
to know who said the [ __ ] crucified
got them through their their dj made ggs
dj mania yeah cheryl says
cheryl says my man sucks he only likes
industrial so frustrating i like how you
live like that yeah honestly um
i kind of like
it i'm kind of like movies like that too
i'm just kind of like if it's good i
don't give a [ __ ] what genre it is yeah
just you know
give me something to get obviously i
have my preferences like just like i do
with movies yeah i prefer to watch
horror movies but
i'll watch anything
just like music if it's good i'll listen
to it i don't give a [ __ ] i guess tina's
listening to [ __ ] the army of lovers
right through the group that sings spin
me right around baby yeah dead or alive
dead or alive yeah it is kind of well i
don't know if you're listening to it or
you're just looking at it tila because
that
that one guy looks like that dude he
does a bit but um the sound is a lot
different
pete burns that guy's name yeah uh from
dead or alive yeah
but um
yeah
cheryl says the cramps oh my god you're
speaking my language oh my god i [ __ ]
love the cramps honestly every now and
then every now and then not often enough
in my opinion
but every now and then if we're at eye
bar which is called barbarella now
he'll play
what's inside a girl that's pretty much
the only cramped song he played i think
he played bikini girls with machine guns
a couple times but normally if he's
going to play the crams he plays what's
inside a girl which is fine with me
because that's an awesome song but
once every few months he'll play it and
i just get all kind of excited
because he just never plays it otherwise
it's just kind of like when i get
excited when he plays like alien sexy
and i walk the line
which again
maybe once every six months or so but i
get excited when it happens
uh john gore says b-52s were a great
band
yeah i mean i'm not like a massive fan
but yeah i really do like the b52s and
honestly um
the dude from b-52s
every time they that he plays here every
time that they played here comes the
club yeah he comes to eye bar so because
he knows uh john that oh he was standing
right behind me so we've seen him i've
seen him like lots of times every time
they're in town he's always at eibar i
even know who he was
he was standing right behind us remember
yeah i even had to do this well
like i said i had seen him there fred
schneider his name is yeah um
sorry i just thought of a song monster
there's a monster in my pants and yeah
that was like early 80s but yeah he he
hangs out there all the time so i've
seen him there like multiple times
that's the thing about ibarr is that
whatever band is playing there if
they're kind of like a new wave or
you know punk or post punk kind of band
normally after their show you'll see
them at i because everybody went to
eyebar like after even the bands so
but fred schneider was like uh he was a
friend of the he's a friend of a friend
of our friend john gardner yeah who owns
the place so he would always whenever
the b52s or he was in town they would
always be there
rock lobster they play a lot of b-52s at
that club a lot of defense he's also
friends with [ __ ] zymox
that's right also known as klan as imox
they're really good actually t would
probably like them
t uh go look for a band called [ __ ]
um
clan of zymox they're dutch yes they're
dutch z-x-y-m-o-x
zymox they're really good you're really
good
they went i kind of feel like they were
more goth rock yeah in the 80s and 90s
and then they went like a little more
industrial direction yeah which was fine
i mean it was still good but i think i
like their older [ __ ] like jasmine or
rose and stuff like that better
yeah they came to the club [ __ ]
played in a little small venue we were
jamming out they're good they're they're
they're good let me see if i can find
some [ __ ] zion what they look like
murder corner return says obsession if
you're talking about the animotion song
i'm going to like categorically get it
because honestly i love 80s music
for whatever reason that [ __ ]
animotion song rubs me the wrong goddamn
way yeah so every time even back in the
80s i was just kind of like nope i don't
know what it is about that one
particular song that i really can't
stand but there's something about it so
every time they play it i'm just kind of
like nope i'm going to the bathroom bye
i think i hate that one worse than the
french one
i mean the french one at least has
at least has some like that hot girl in
it that you can look at
she's an old french porn star
which you know i'm like okay well i can
be mollified by that
the animation video just has terrible
people wearing terrible 80s clothes with
terrible 80s hair
and a terrible
cynthia ass song that
rubs me the wrong way you know as klan
as imox they're real real good oh [ __ ]
they're really good
xymox they've been around forever
forever it started off the bad's name
was called zymox and then it became clan
of zymox later
but it's kind of like
gothic
industrial
but it's not hard it's almost kind of
ambient
and poppy sounding in some certain
certain ways it's just very addictive
real smooth
it's good
yeah i kind of feel like their older
stuff sounded almost like i don't want
to say it sounded
kind of like sisters or mercy more like
the mission uk yeah that kind of area
not exactly the same but that kind of
area
uh danny rowling says it's danzig wig
time time
really
okay
dj maniac asks uh plastic bertrand no
that's not the one i'm talking about
it's um
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is the name of that
song
god damn it i've seen it enough because
they play it pretty much every [ __ ]
saturday
and every time i go ah here we go again
at least i can look at the hot chick
with the bank okay yeah
oh [ __ ] is the name of that song
god damn it what the [ __ ] is the name of
that [ __ ] i used to speak french
thank you jeffy art i'm meeting up at my
friend's pool party to kick off the
three-day weekend just wanted to say
thank you both so much for the content
stay awesome thank you so much thank you
for dropping by for you were also
awesome you have fun at that party
uh no d4m2 says i'll always be grateful
for a guitar hero
introducing my kids to alternative forms
of music see that's another thing like i
said
dude
yeah yeah yeah
because sometimes listen to that song
i'm like oh my god i know what she's
saying because i took four years of
french in high school yeah yeah she's
just talking about moreto when you laugh
when you smile something like that yeah
yeah yeah
i don't know why that song pisses me off
so much it's just
she goes
it just pisses me off i don't know why
well like i said it's it's the same with
like obsession by an emotion even though
it doesn't sound all that different to
other songs that came out in the 80s for
some reason that would just like pisses
me off and i don't really know why
it just makes me angry like every time
it comes on i'm like no
i'll put up with a lot of [ __ ] from the
80s
you know
but she's talking to moreto whoever
morata is
one thing that i will complain about and
like i said you know
we've been going we haven't gone in a
while because it's far now but
uh you know eyebar slash barbarella
which like i said they're moving now
actually they're having a thing tonight
but
i was kind of like wait do i really want
to like get ready and go because we have
to go monday for memento mori and it's
so far and i was like i don't know if i
want to pay for like two nights and one
weekend her name is bridgette bridgette
lahi
okay that's right
she's super hot though i will give her
that yeah
bush though
that's okay yeah yeah i'm not i'm not
bothered
i'm not bothered by girl bush
dive in
no i'm just saying it's like it's a you
know dive in if that's how you want to
roll i'm just i'm not going to complain
about it it's fine i think her name is
british no that's not her that's not her
he's like never that's not her
all right i'm gonna go to the bathroom
you like you find some like some porn or
some whatever i'm gonna try to figure
out who it is
i forgot what her name was
i used to know i feel like but i don't i
don't know anywhere
i'm sitting here trying to figure out
who it is
not the ferrari
i can't find it
i can't find it people
let's see what everybody's doing let me
get back on the [ __ ] show
oh yeah thrill kill coal yeah they're
good
let's see
so somebody says that song isn't it
maniac knows the name of that song
because that song is a nightmare what is
the name of that [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is it
they play it like every [ __ ] saturday
black [ __ ] bob haircut and i mean
yeah this is back in the 80s and she's
[ __ ] dancing like that
and she's uh
she's a [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah what the [ __ ] is the name of that
[ __ ] tongue yeah yeah so i went in
the bathroom and my bathroom has two
doors right so i close both doors
and then pookie pops out of the closet
like
yeah you're in the shoes you
i guess she was in the closet
she like popped out i i don't know if
she was hiding in my laundry basket i
don't know what the [ __ ] she was doing
holy [ __ ]
uh pokey so weird
um
daddy rolling hair pie is rare pie it is
i mean you know
bob marley said oh my god bob marley's
back from the dead uh black folks with
rebel flags certainly confuses the
yankee taurus blows their minds
i guess we were talking about like what
we were talking about earlier about like
yeah leonard skinner yeah connection
but uh yeah so i can't i don't know why
like i said i like the video uh that
girl is super hot or she was back in the
80s i don't know what she looks like
nowadays
but for whatever reason that song just
[ __ ] rubs me the wrong way i guess i
don't know i know you do so it's like
every time it comes on tom's like yay
and i'm just like
[ __ ] you man yeah
and i'm always kind of like
why
like i said i'll put up with a lot
although i will say
that
one thing that
did kind of bother me a lot about
eyebrows
barbarella was that saturday night
saturday nights are the best
you know that's the 80s new wave night
uh usually it's better [ __ ] is played
earlier
um so you got to get there kind of early
because you know they'll play because
the the more the night goes on the more
they're gonna play like
pet shop boys erasure
stuff like that which
is fine but
not really
i don't know
early on they'll play stuff like killing
joke or
you know the cramps or
something like that like they'll play
like some weirder [ __ ] because they know
like some more people aren't there
but as time goes on they'll kind of play
more like quote unquote popular stuff
it's like we'll play depeche mode we'll
play like enjoy the silence which you
know so it'll be like that
but
that was 1980s or was it 1990s i don't
even remember
it might have been 90s
it might be it might be
uh adrian asks uh do you guys probably
like more syphilitica um honestly i
don't know that much about them i
remember like reading some articles
about them in like [ __ ]
uh gothic beauty and [ __ ] like that like
back in the 90s
but i think i have a couple of
compilations that have their songs on it
and i remember them being very good but
yeah
ethereal stuff i do kind of like that
tom likes that probably more than i do
you like that kind of ethereal goth kind
of thing i like that too but i think you
like it more than i do
i'm more of like in a long time i'm more
of like a post punk yeah grungy kind of
[ __ ] not grunge but
more of a postponed kind of person
ethereal shit's good too though i like a
lot of
anyone did cocktail
yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah honestly um
cocktail twins
i had that one album of theirs that was
like a best of was it a best of or it
was like a compilation had pearly drop
dewdrops drop on it had um [ __ ] uh
from the flagstones it had like all the
it was just like so good man i listened
to that so many times in the [ __ ] 90s
just over and over and over again i
think i wore it out i had to like buy it
again
so yeah i i really like
remember they got like kind of popular
for a minute when blue bell nola came
out
because they had uh that song carolyn's
tears but carolyn's tears was out with
the name of it
and um
yeah i think that was the name of it
and that was a great ass song i think
that's another one that i have on my
phone but uh yeah what a brand of tablet
does tom have uh it's a [ __ ] lg
i think it's called a galaxy something
or other
that's samsung galaxy i don't know man
you're asking like this is like boomer
tech man this is [ __ ] i don't know
what any of this [ __ ] is i don't know
it's magic i don't know what's mad
that's what they sold me
but they sold me man my phone's a galaxy
but it's a samsung i'm pretty sure lg
and samsung are two different companies
which i know because i did some uh
advertising work for lg
like a couple years ago those are two
different companies
i can't find i can't find the name of
that [ __ ] woman it doesn't matter
carolyn's fingers there we go
that's the name of that song
yeah i was really into that song blue
belt mold that album was i have that
album i have
what the [ __ ] was the name of that the
pink opaque was that the name of that i
had it on a head on cassette actually
i don't know if i have it anymore
but i mean i have it in my itunes but i
don't think i have the cassette anymore
because i threw out a lot of my
cassettes because they were all moldy
yeah it's the galaxy tab
yeah
okay i don't care about that [ __ ] man
[Laughter]
pepper charm remembers
let's see uh anyone remember the leaving
trains that name is familiar i remember
hearing maybe
one song of theirs
so
i don't know let's see uh
what were we gone too bad we can't play
music on the show yeah
i mean we can it's just it'll get
demonetized yeah one's talking about the
misfits um i'm actually kind of a big
fan of the misfits i have a younger
brother he's four years younger
my younger brother
in the late 80s and early 90s was like
the world's biggest miss fitz fan did
you see that 20 super chat that we had
where jeffrey art yeah okay already been
addressed okay and he learned to play
guitar from listening to the misfits and
also bad religion
so he basically my whole entire like
older teenage years because his bedroom
was next to mine like in the apartment
and
so basically my whole entire teenage
years i was listening to like you know
joy division alien sex being about house
and stuff and the niece over there
listening to like the misfits and bad
religion which i like to
and so like be coming through the wall
and him like practicing but that's how
he learned to play guitar like misfits
and bad religion and he was actually in
a band that covered
they did their own original songs too
but they did like a lot of misfits and
bad religion covers as well and they
played around a lot in daytona and i
think they played some shows in deland
and orlando
too if i'm not mistaken i remember going
to see them quite a bit like i said he's
four years younger
uh yeah misfits astro zombies got any
sisters jenny i do uh i have a sister
named amanda
and she is seven years younger seven
years younger yeah i was born in 72 and
she was born in 79 i just saw her not
too long ago she came to florida
to go
she did a vacation at disney which she
does usually every year
normally her boyfriend comes but he
couldn't come this year so she came by
herself so she stayed at like uh disney
and universal or whatever for like a
week and then she came to ocala to visit
my mom so i drove over there to ocala to
hang out with her and my mom one day so
me and my sister it's funny because
we're seven years apart
um and we didn't even really grow up
together because my parents divorced
when i was 14
and my
youngest sister my youngest brother
moved in with my mom and me and my four
years younger brother
moved in with my dad
so we still saw our brother and sister
but not
every day
but
it's really weird because we're so like
far apart in age and from what i've
heard of other people that have siblings
it's like oh my god we're so different
me and all my brothers and my sister are
almost exactly the same
even though we're like super far apart
in age even my youngest brother who was
born in [ __ ] 1986 for christ's sake
which to me seems very very young
um
honestly
yeah we're very very similar which is
[ __ ] crazy what
uh me and my siblings
are all very similar yeah which like i
said is weird because we're really far
apart in age but
for whatever reason we got all the same
genetics we are all into like similar
kinds of music we're all kind of like
punk rocker trying to get me to get
dancing with her
cheryl says i think you're mistaken
jenny there's no way you're more than 35
yeah i wish i was no more than 35 but
starting to get up there man getting old
honestly sometimes i think about my
siblings
and i remember them when they were kids
and i'm just kind of like oh my god
now my my brother
is in his 40s now too and i was just
like holy [ __ ] i remember he was like
[ __ ] teenager in a punk band holy
crap
crazy everybody gets old though
you're making my [ __ ] go blurry
because my [ __ ] magnetic personality
make that [ __ ] go blurry is that what it
is yeah the camera can't stand it no of
course not taking a magnetic field
it's like iron man from [ __ ]
the iron man as told you about ozzy
osbourne
i put it within reach because i knew
you'd probably want it
they're talking about the danzig movie
are you talking about what the [ __ ] was
that movie called
what was that i didn't see that [ __ ] i
wouldn't watch one of dancing movies
veronica veronica
that motherfucker's full of [ __ ] i kind
of wanted to watch it but then like i
saw a bunch of uh reviews of it and
everybody's like please don't bother
it's like the worst thing ever and i was
just kind of like
i was like yeah i could kind of see that
i could kind of see that well
dan dig glen danzig he seems like one of
those maybe not to this degree but he
seems like
one of those [ __ ] like steven
seagal where he seems like you know what
i mean we're going to put his eggs
against steven seagal in the same
universe i said not to the same degree
to be fair
it's all a spectrum steven seagal being
at the one end of the spectrum the
extreme end of the spectrum
but it's it's in that more in that
direction yeah i'm just saying dudes
that
believe in their own hype to an extent
that they don't really have any
self-awareness
about how
lame they appear to other people yeah
and
i kind of feel i'm sorry danzig i do
like a lot of stuff but i do kind of
feel like he has a little bit of that
a little bit of that
that's all i'm saying yeah
that you're not really aware
because
from what i heard i haven't seen the
movie
from what i heard about the movie and i
did read i was curious so i like read
the synopsis of it and i was like that
sounds like
a 14 year old boy trying to be edgy
to me
um
so i was like should i
watch that
at some point i should maybe i'll just
put it on the background while i'm doing
something else so i don't feel like i'm
wasting my time but you know what i mean
i'm thinking about dancing you know
let's kind of be realistic with this
[ __ ] oh wait we were red for a second
okay we're fine yeah because i'm having
i'm having problems over here with this
too it's back on right yeah it's better
okay
oh maybe not
because you're talking bad about dancing
talking bad about dancing dante owns the
internet
well we've solved the mystery
juan says danzig is the new ed wood he
you know what he very well liked peter
says i passed no he didn't of course i
did [ __ ] t you were missing the game
you missed you don't know i've been
[ __ ] up in the game since you've been
gone
and i have incorporated the [ __ ] eye
patch this increases my sexual potency i
mean he has a whole thing yeah it
increases my sexual potency
you need i'm like a gay pirate now do
you know what you need what's that you
need a three-cornered hat with a feather
in it yeah
you also need
some tights stockings yeah
and some buckled shoes
and some breeches
no you do though okay [ __ ] all this let
me let me get up
jenny's trying to take me down another
path i'm not i'm just she's going on
into homosexual fantasies and [ __ ] she's
trying to get me to go down in a gay
route
looking i'm trying to stay focused on
things like important things
like seagal and [ __ ] ed
and
action is important and [ __ ] but i'm
gonna have to [ __ ] talk about
dancing okay
i'm gonna give credit where credit's due
danzig when he uh [ __ ] with the
misfits he did a good job i love the
mismatch
and uh when when his first solo album
came out you know [ __ ] danzig had
mother on it had a bunch of that whole
album was really good twist the cane
and he pro that band progressively got
better it it was that i thought it got
better all the way out till dad's at
five
and then i started to kind of check out
i was going off into other things and
kind of forgetting about danzig
he would say some crazy [ __ ] in the old
media of the time and couldn't defend
himself
i think the problem with danzig is
if you ever see where he lived he lived
out in l.a in this little [ __ ] house
and um
he didn't change much over the years so
he didn't grow that's kind of the
problem i had with like from what i uh
could glean about the movie that he made
yeah it seemed like he was doing like
what in the early 90s would have been
considered like super edgy
and nowadays everyone's just like you're
right
okay so i think what happened was is uh
he had his little
when he first appeared the timing was
right he was real current
and he got caught in that rut
he did do a cool a lot of cool [ __ ] you
know i mean he was [ __ ]
but unlike steven seagal i don't like
steven segov
i said it but he kind of got caught into
it into uh too much into his own
uh
kind of formula
and he vanished up his own ass yeah
that's a good way of putting it a
[ __ ] crawling up inside his own
[ __ ] he turned himself inside out
almost in the mass masturbatory [ __ ]
thing where he loves himself so much
he's now in his own universe
and but on the outside world things are
progressing and moving but moving past
so then every time he comes out with
something new it kind of feels like
something old yes instead of something
new
it's hard to be a satanist in a world of
it's hard in a world where nobody thinks
that's weird or edgy or anything
hard to be a satanist in a world of
atheists
but i understand it because this
struggle yeah
i understand it because you know
growing up
being born in 69 going through the 70s
and the 80s and the 90s
um most of the metal scene was actually
if you if you analyze the content of
metal albums
all of metal depends upon a christian
viewpoint
almost all of it
well yeah because their whole shtick is
like subverting it yeah of being the
devil the devil and the devil [ __ ]
doing things and it's like we're the
band that your mom doesn't want you to
listen to you and then magical mystical
mornings and [ __ ] elves and [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
hobbies of course says evil adc yeah
eviling ain't easy yeah right especially
nowadays
uh so
[Laughter]
just watch t let me explain some [ __ ] to
you t
being a sister from another dimension
being adopted by the white folks through
marriage
to understand the [ __ ] old school
heavy metal
genre you have to [ __ ] go back
to the craziness of the 70s and the prog
rock movement and [ __ ]
led zeppelin and [ __ ] black sabbath
and all that [ __ ] and deal and rainbow
and all that
the guy who captures it the best is
actually [ __ ] what's his name and
from [ __ ] uh jack black
go [ __ ] watch a jack black movie
called tenacious d
okay that take that actually explains it
and takes it it makes it funny all right
um jack black understands exactly what
it is
old school metal is now a meme it's a
[ __ ] meme yeah okay
you can put that in a box it's now
something in the past and it was
you can't make that relevant anymore
right which which
i mean that's like everything from the
hit from yeah the old days you can when
i listen to that [ __ ] i go back in time
sure to that mindset of the
with the exception of some of the some
of the bands
like that
70s metal
album that i recommended to you from
judas priest [ __ ] sad wings of
destiny it is kind of its own thing
it's a little bit outside of time sin
after sin the album that came out
afterwards afterwards is also kind of in
its own class in its own class but most
most metal was very dated very much a
product of its place in time
and it's it's christian even if it's
[ __ ] talking about the devil and [ __ ]
in order for you to even talk about the
devil you have to have a christian
viewpoint
well and like i said i think the the
problem arises is that if your whole
shtick is in shocking the normies yeah
um that's not gonna age all that well
because like 20 30 years from now the
normies are gonna like those normies are
gone those normies are gone or
everyone's like consciousness has been
expanded to a point where that's not
shocking anymore and now it just seems
like you're a big [ __ ] try hard yeah
so and metal was it's not gonna hit the
metal was try hard
even though yeah i think that's kind of
why i wasn't really into it even though
i'm very artists oh [ __ ] is it red okay
no it went right the masters at it like
ronnie james dio
sure a lot of that shit's great but
it is very tryhard he could write some
[ __ ] badass magical mystical lyrics
and take you to another universe and he
sounded like this big powerful [ __ ]
ryan james dear was a little [ __ ]
like uh five foot three dude who could
[ __ ] little bitty skinny five foot
three guy
who could [ __ ] give us very [ __ ]
powerful performance everybody loved him
he died of cancer poor ronnie
um he was in black sabbath and did he's
in rainbow he was in black sabbath he
was in uh his own band called okay i'm
gonna wait for that [ __ ] to pass
we got a red line i don't know if you
guys can hear me or not
okay that's green it's back and great
all right um
but uh ronnie was [ __ ] he was a
genius um but if you go back and listen
to like
[ __ ] it went red again yeah
wait a minute
usually i mean we had this uh we had
this on wednesday too yeah
i don't remember ever having this much
problem maybe over a couple of days i
thought they were just doing like
[ __ ] mate answers i don't know we'll
see
come on it's coming it looks like it
might be trying to come back i don't
know i'm trying to re reconnect let's
try it hard
what does it say about the the data
stream i see the move well it hasn't
disconnected so that's something but
if it goes to zero for a certain amount
of time it will disconnect and then it
automatically will try to reconnect yeah
okay i'm gonna put my shield i'm going
like [ __ ]
okay okay
it's going back okay
is it bad yeah okay looks it's back i
went ahead and turned my [ __ ] way down
yeah
yeah
let's talk about ronnie ronnie james
ryan james deal sure he's kind of like
the ultimate try hard
when you listen to [ __ ] ronnie james
he that [ __ ] is kind of a meme
especially his lyrics
his whole thing was to try to transport
you into another [ __ ] world and when
you really analyze it his world is
basically kind of like the world of
dungeons and dragons yeah it's like some
tolkien yeah it's like sometimes it's
like it's nerdy it's it's kind of very
nerdy which in the 80s that absolutely
would have been considered nerdy yeah
yeah
so that that's the place where metal
came from yeah and uh when
iron maiden appeared you know first it
was just kind of most about serial
killers the first couple albums and
edgar allen poe
but then when
you had guys like bruce dickinson when
he got involved he's taking it more to a
classical
background he's going to teach you
history
history and literature so the next thing
you know well actually he's singing it
but it's [ __ ] steve harris doing all
the writing
and that kind of aged
that kind of age now the sudden [ __ ]
iron maiden becomes a history lesson and
english lit
is teaching you english literature and
so this [ __ ] can kind of gel
after a while and it becomes kind of not
cool after two or three albums
danzig [ __ ] got on to the damn satan
rock and roll thing now there had other
bands that were doing that
uh you know venom and slayer with slayer
was more the serial killer stuff but
venom was more purely satanist